From LoC + Smithsonian NMAAHC.
This is Emily Crosby with the Southern oral history program at the University of North Carolina at Chapel Hill.
And I'm conducting this oral history as part of the Civil Rights History Project, sponsored by the Smithsonian Institution's National Museum of American History and Culture
and the American Folklife Center and the Library of Congress.
Today is August 23rd, 2013, and we are with Ekwueme Michael Thelwell at his home in Pelham, Massachusetts this morning.
And I'm here with John Bishop, who's the videographer.
Thank you Professor Delwell for doing the interview with us.
Thank you Professor Crosby.
I'm happy to do this interview.
Can you think of an interviewer I'd be happy to do it with and yourself?
You do me honor, sir.
I'm a humble servant of the truth Professor, a humble servant of the truth.
Can you tell us about your family growing up in Jamaica?
Yes, I could, if it were necessary.
My father as a young man came to the United States and spent some time, some considerable time there.
I was quite a legend as I walked through New York, through Harlem.
People say, here is sun, here is sun and there are a lot of stories about my father.
He was a very dramatic figure.
He had a deep boom in laugh, an obvious love of people.
He was six foot four, 240 pounds, which in that day on the edge made him a giant.
Or he was a professional footballer, lying back today.
In this country, he was a motorcycle race, with a motorcycle very big back in the 30s and 40s.
And a trick writer.
He went back to Jamaica, entered politics, was elected in his constituency.
It was very, very popular with the people, look at his generous and kind.
And people said if he hadn't died at age of 44, he probably would have been Prime Minister of the country.
And there was much speculation that death was a consequence of political conspiracies and wickedness, which is the way people tended to think.
My mother was an amazing woman because she brought the thru of herself after my father died.
I was interested, so a lot of his property was hung up, all kinds of litigation and bureaucracy.
And she raised three children, sent us to the best school in the country.
My brother became an engineer, went to University of Michigan on an athletic scholarship.
And he was six foot five and very black.
And he was an excellent athlete.
He represented the country and track and field when still a high school boy.
And he was an international soccer team when still a high school student.
And my mother, who was imperious, had been told such a thing that athletic scholarships existed.
She collected all his clippings, flew to this country, went to the University of Michigan, walked into the athletic directors office with all these clippings, trying to remember the guy's name.
And when she walked over to my brother, I had a scholarship.
So my brother arrives here and is running track for Michigan.
That lasted one year.
Didn't last as long as a year because the academic advisors to the athletic department,
told him that he should major in physical education and become a coach.
I mean, here, yeah, this big black guy with a Jamaican accent.
Obviously, Physiologist, the major, and he should come.
He said, no, he must be able to do mine.
That came here to become a civil engineer.
So, oh, no, no, you got to major in physical education.
You can't handle civil engineering.
So he told them to kiss his behind and give them back a scholarship and stop competing on his work as way through Michigan.
On five years later, he graduated with a bachelor's degree in civil engineering, a master's degree in sanitary engineering, and another master's degree in environmental engineering.
But I do have this great picture of him running against, as a freshman running against two seniors.
They were dead even, so it had to have been the first hurdle.
And on one side of him is Len Bonny, who went on to grade fame in the National Football League, and on the other side of him is Herb Adley, who also went on to be a first-rate defensive back, and maybe a hall of fame.
And there is my 18-year-old brother right in the middle of them running like hell.
Did he miss the video of any regrets about walking away from the athletic?
He never expressed any.
Back in see how he couldn't have.
Younger brother.
Actually, his story is really interesting because he was three months premature. He was more or not six months.
And only with 20,500 phones.
So some members of the family are looking at this little creature saying, he never going to live through him away.
You know, dash him away.
But my mother fed him with an eyedropper from one of those medicine bottles of associate fed him.
And he had to only survive just three and a half-pound birth weight.
But he grew to six foot five, and was probably the most phenomenal schoolboy athlete the country ever produced.
And also as an excellent environmental engineer, he went back and set up for the government,
the Department of Natural Resources and Conservation in the Jamaican government,
and was a consultant to the United Nations in that field until he prematurely died.
And the eyedroboat 60.
When you came to this country, did you have much sense of the soil?
Is that something you were thinking about at the time?
I had some sense of the racial circumstances in the country.
And I had a deep seat to dread of the South.
One of the books that I'd read in Heiss, who was John Oliver Killens' young blood,
which is a very powerful book, had such an effect on me.
And also the kind of romances of, was this black guy who used to write all these romances, the The Foxes of Harrow?
Frank Yerby.
Okay, here.
So I had a serious fear and dread of the South.
The first time I went to Louisiana and saw those, what are those,
Spanish, that grown the trees?
My heart fell and I became petrified with fear, just the image of the Spanish.
I mean, I never, other sense of the South, I got from Faulkner.
And then in addition to which, I got to the United States, got to hold university.
In September 1959.
And the spring of 1966, the student freedom rights happened.
So I've often claimed that I arrived in this country and touched off the student movement in the South.
I arrived when I touched the top.
People have tended to contest that.
It advised people, misguided people, have tended to contest that.
And obviously you arrived, it's very, very important.
How did you come to Howard?
The sequential file, as you have this say.
How did I come to Howard?
Yeah.
And rather not say.
Okay.
My formal answer to that question is, I wanted to go to a black school,
so I could be immersed in black culture and develop an African-American perspective on the world.
That's my official position.
The real position was, as we're considered, the American industrial corporation.
And a young economist came in, the other master's degree in economy from Howard University, Conor and Pain.
He was very elegant, very dark guy, spoken a very affected way.
And naturally I gravitated to him because here's this genuine intellectual black mind.
And he said, you got to go to Howard University, Washington DC, there are nine women forever men.
And every male student at Howard, have at least three or four girlfriends at the same time.
I said, that's all I want to know.
That's the real reason I went to Howard.
You needed those cards?
I beg your pardon?
I said, you needed those cards?
No, I didn't forget. I needed them, but I wouldn't hurt.
Not going to throw them down.
There's an evil proverb, which says, only a fool spits out the tender muscle that a kind God places between his lips.
And then you won that kind of fool.
No, man. I've been called everything with a child, a guy, and a Republican.
And you know, ain't nobody ever called me a fool.
So what was Howard like for you? What was your life?
Amazing.
That is the best decision anybody ever made for the wrong reasons.
You know, anything people want to know about a student experience at Howard,
they can read and comment because they're great for revolution.
Who was at Howard with us?
As was Courtland Cox, as was Charlie Cobb.
There was a whole host of us since the group came through Howard.
And that's not accidental.
The first thing is Howard was very strategically placed.
Being in the nation's capital, and as you know, they're only federally supported black institution in the country,
which created interest in political problems because the people who control the whole university budget were also done congressmen,
all dixacrites, all white supremacists, and segregationists.
So that for example, in the four years I was here, and a member of NAG.
NAG was never recognized student organization.
The NAACP was a recognized student organization.
The French club was a recognized student organization.
The German club was a recognized student organization, but NAG was not.
Are we following that very distressing?
When it turns out that President Mordecai Johnson and then the President and the neighbor knew exactly what they were doing.
So when they went to get their budgets from Congress, and people say,
all of them are liberals, run around the place, beans are disruptive.
Can you control them?
You say, but Mr. Congressmen, Mr. Senator, I've scrutinized the student organizations at Howard University very carefully.
There's no non-violent action group there, and such an organization doesn't exist as far as our record show.
It must be young people from Georgetown and Georgetown and Washington, and those are the schools.
But it gave us an excellent issue around which to organize,
because every year we went to the large campaign to get NAACP recognized.
And I had to tell you, in my own case, I was not even aware of the strategy of protecting us that a university president was doing.
So we thought of an expression of whole-backedness and reaction-nearness that it wouldn't recognize us.
I was struggled, and even students who weren't very politically active,
who was well-for-turned-it-to-greetly to students, when we started saying,
oh, come this non-violent action group is not recognized, they turned out in demonstrate enough, fear.
The student government would make statements that would all be recognized by the university health very firm,
or they never recognized, so it didn't formally and officially exist.
What point did you understand what they were doing?
Long after I had left.
But, honest, it didn't have to be grateful for the issue to organize our own.
We could get the school year started with a political confrontation with the administration.
Anything drop to go to...
Right, precisely. You need an issue to organize our own.
So NAACP seems like one of the strongest of the student groups that was a sneak affiliate,
at least sort of over the long period of time,
is do you think that's accurate?
That depends on what you mean by strong.
First of all, our university attracted students from all over the country and all over the world.
It was very central at the place.
Prior to the reason we organized NAACP was that once the student's sit-ins and the soul started,
we took the position that looked, we're here in the nation's capital.
We have a moral and a political obligation to support all brothers and sisters in the south.
Therefore, the seat of government is here, the white horses here, the capital is here.
We can't have demonstrations there to put pressure on these southerners.
And it's so duty and responsibility to do it.
Then there was segregation in Maryland, there was segregation in Virginia.
So you could drive out to the district of Columbia and have, you know, bona fide sit-ins.
And so it's, it's a failure of our responsibility to do history if the students are told they're an active in that way.
That's number one.
Number two, there were professors here, unfortunately, there's a historian whose name I'm not going to remember,
who gave us very contemporary readings, political readings.
And there was a quality, there was a level of instruction among certain of the faculty there.
That was very focused on social issues and very focused on educating the assessor of the state of the world.
And in addition to which, a health percentage of the African American students came out of this deep southerner.
For example, there were Cleve Sellers who came from South Carolina into Nug.
And Cleve was sent to hold by his parents because white folks had won them in the community.
That is, he continued to agitate in the way he was agitated.
And he was probably going to come to a very bad end.
So they sent him or to hold to safety.
And the first thing he does is he's drunk afterwards to put some giants in Nug.
You know, and comes back, don't so.
And that was also true of Hank Thomas, Hank Thomas.
Hank Thomas came from St. Augustine, Florida.
And he maintained a constant protest against the discrimination in a part that surrounded them there.
As a matter of fact, a friend of his joined over the department, Clay Thelbenjerman,
and said, you know, he and Frank were very close growing up.
So, principally, he said, the only entertainment we had in Fort Augustin was to go to the movies on a Saturday.
Well, we had to sit up in the cross-ness and the segregated era.
He said, on the front, Frank was about 14 years old until he left high school.
He refused to go because he refused to pay his money and be discriminated against.
That's the kind of principle he had.
And he was a big burliger, still as tall, big,
and had a scholarship to play defensive end.
I believe at the University of Wisconsin.
And instead, he came to Hollywood, worked in the cafeteria, didn't have any scholarship, didn't play football, and joined the movement.
So there was a mixture of young people at Hollywood.
Some of them from the deep south, La Vaughan, I never forget him.
He was in a room next door to me.
He was from Birmingham.
He was a short, wire little black guy who was a veteran.
And he was the first one who told me about conditions in the deep south.
I was a freshman just off the plane. I used to talk to La Vaughan.
And see, you're from out of the bomb on my brother.
He told me about it, and he educated me.
He told me about Tuskegee.
He said, man, in fact, when Niggas are Tuskegee, he said, you know, they make good money.
They're professors, so they have new cars.
When they leave Tuskegee, I'm going to the rural.
They put on a chauffeur's hat to drive the cars through,
because a Nigga and a good car is going to have a heat patrol from them crackers.
I think, good guy, I don't know, he said, oh, yeah, I'm going to get all carried out chauffeurs hat to them.
So, look at a driving white folk car.
And then they said, we've got a police chief.
Now, this is 1959, September, right?
So, it predates, and then he a mean cracker.
I said, yeah, what's his name?
The bull.
I said, what's his name?
Bull.
And he went to the guys whammy, and they said,
some Niggas took his eye out in a fight,
and he'd do hit black people.
So, what's his name?
He said, bull, Bull Connor.
In 1963, I would discover who he was talking about.
So, he, and a lot of other stories that he told me,
I really educated, he had terrified me.
And he also told me something about the educational policies of the assault,
because I didn't have much money.
We also got there.
If you want us to call for a shock and trauma,
is the first time that students from the Caribbean go into the cafeteria.
Now, the prices in the whole cafeteria were dirt cheap in American standards.
Well, then somebody said, man,
you see what it cost me for breakfast?
It cost me $1.50.
And the currency was what you need on for a week, you know?
So, I had to learn to cook very quickly.
So, I was very broke.
My father was dead.
My mother didn't have much money.
She sent me a regular stipend over month,
which required some sacrifice for her.
And it translated into $30 a week a month.
So, that was my income.
Right, which she sent it ever once.
So, we had to find different things to do.
I used to cut here in the dorm.
I hated the dorm care of her and told me that the bar was union in Washington,
DC, I'd heard of both of them was taking steps to have me stopped.
And for a while, I believed them.
They said they got to send the lawyer stack.
I got to eat, you know?
Oh, we're talking about leaven.
One someone, if you come and say, Mac,
you look hungry, I'm going to buy you a stick.
I'll go to the canyon grill and he'd buy me this tea one stick.
I cut it in $2.50, which is a hell of an expenditure for one meal.
And he says,
Mac, enjoy your stick.
Enjoy your stick.
The great stator, Alibaba, gives it to you with their compliments.
And I said, what are you talking about, Liv?
Look, man, then crackers don't want us to go to the Lille White School.
So, they pay me money to go to school out of the state.
So, he had both his stuff from the military
and the stipend from the state of Alibaba,
which gave me a stick once a month, you know?
So, you're grateful for the stick of Alibaba for that?
And then gratitude, permanent and undone gratitude.
You don't say,
and nobody ever benefited even slightly from racism.
And sometimes, Leaven would buy me two sticks.
I have another one, Micah, still look hungry.
Understand about Obama.
And you did your best to pay back the stick of Alibaba, right?
Yeah, I thought I owed it to them.
Okay, as a consequence of segregation,
some truly excellent and politically active, right?
Professor Eugene Clay Holmes, for example,
who in the H.U.A.C.
summoned him to speak out to, what is your profession?
He said, sir, I am a hired thinker.
What is yours?
And Eugene Clay Holmes, with good friends,
or so he cleaned with Bertrand Russell.
So, for an occasion, he'd come to class and said,
oh, I had to let it from Bertrand "Bertie" Russell today.
What does a host of professors, historians,
and like Sterling A. Brown and literature and stuff like that,
who in today's academic climate,
if they didn't have the consciousness to stay at a black school,
would probably be at one of the elite private,
Ivy League institutions, and they'd be very celebrated,
whether he's got a state authority, E. Franklin Frazier,
the sociologist, and a host of people like that.
So, we had that exposure, and they had certain programs,
reading programs and discussion programs,
to really make sure that we, that are social and political education.
Not brainwashing, but at that sense.
What they were really distoying was a sense of the necessity
for social responsibility and a part of young people.
And those students who were attuned to that, gravitated to that,
and they're sorted up.
Carmichael talks about it at some considerable length in his book.
So, there are people like Courtland Cargs, Charlie Cobb,
myself, Stokely Carmichael, Muriel Tillinghast.
A really brilliant young man who was head of the student government,
when I got there, Philadelphia, Negro, he became a lawyer,
and a Republican, whom I talked about, Tim Jenkins.
Yeah, a very brilliant young man, Tim Jenkins,
who was head of the student union when I got there, student government.
I had gotten there and I truly wasn't impressed
with the quality of the bureaucrats who filled up at least.
And when they had a little dorm spoke to us,
I thought he was dormant of like we're a school children.
And when the dean of students spoke to us,
I thought he was an embassy.
And at this great orientation, we had an up-get Tim Jenkins,
head of the student government,
and the most articulate, the most politically clear,
the most mature speech that was made in that conversation,
was made by the head of the student government.
So, Tim Jenkins immediately had a big fan in me.
And he was a guy who worked to set up the orientation session
for SNCC when SNCC got started.
And entered into the established,
he became an office of NSA, national student organization,
and directed a lot of support to SNCC.
So, there was that kind of environment,
intellectual and social environment at home.
And in addition to which, and this was very important to me,
the nation's capital, it was the site of embassies.
And Jamaica became independent while I was at home,
and it says about Jamaica Embassy.
And Ghana had a Ghana in embassies.
So, there were a lot of these African embassies open,
a lot of Caribbean embassies open.
So, there was a low cost somewhere within the diplomatic life,
in terms of world politics, rated very low.
But we had embassies, we had ambassadors,
we could go visit them.
And we did.
The population at home was very interesting.
I only realized after I got there,
that my dentist back in Jamaica,
and my doctor back in Jamaica,
had been educated at home.
So, Haud University had educated a lot of the medical professionals,
and architectural professionals,
and engineering professionals in the black world,
because of the school that was affordable.
You know, the fees were very, very low at that time,
and it played a role across a black diaspora
that was unique in American education history.
So, that, I think there were about 8,000 students at home,
and I was zero.
And I would say that 10 or 15% of them were from Africa,
and another 15, maybe 20% of them were from the Caribbean.
So, that what you had there was a community of young black people,
large numbers who the African Americans were from the South,
or from Chicago, or New York,
and a lot of young people, I mean,
who was that Ghanian politician who was assassinated early?
He was next to Jomo Kenyatta in importance.
No, the movement was Congo.
No, the movement was a Congo.
This is a handsome young, low-man, and boy, a Tom Mboya.
All right.
The Ghanian political leader, Tom Mboya, a handsome young, low-man.
His brother, who looked just like him, came to us at home with us, you know?
I mean, bad, rusting, brought the President to Zambia,
and it's quantum to talk to us.
And quantum came in his book, Jacket and Carkey's stuff.
And I remember when bad introduced me and said,
and it was said in Zambia that Kenneth Kaunda,
the Prime Minister, met a lion in the forest,
and a lion blinked.
That was how he was introduced.
So, it was an extraordinary, heady ambience.
And you know, had to be brain-dead if you didn't,
were inspired by the environment to hold it at that moment
to take political action.
Now, we were.
But we prefaced that way.
You were saying, Nag was one of the strongest groups,
and I didn't know what you meant by strong.
But the fact is, you know, we had in a number of demonstrations,
there was one I will tell you about,
which has to do with the new men's gymnasium.
And we sometimes would put five, you know,
we used to go regularly to pick up the White House, for example.
I would secure some funds from the student government
and we'd rent a bus, we'd bring a third-party campus
and pick up bus loaded people down.
I mean, it may have six to seven to a hundred people
to pick up the White House.
We went to all the core demonstrations.
So it managed to be very active.
And on this particular demonstration,
which concerned the new men's gymnasium,
which Conlikele talks about in his book,
returned to maybe a hundred students from Hollywood
into the streets.
We're active on the root-fought to demonstrations.
We're active on everything that came down,
because all of us had a national focus and a locust.
We had reason to take to the streets.
And what we did, and we organized constantly.
As I said, it was always historical and revolutionary duty.
So I was very amazed when I was working in the Comrade Club book.
And I said, we've got to find out who the membership in Nag was.
And it turns out that the membership in that organization
for four years now is here.
Never exceeded 40 people.
I mean, as a people who would come to meet
and who would plan programs,
who would do all the organizing and work.
And yet, those 40 people in a student population are some eight thousand.
Managed to...
And not insignificant ways of a history.
You're out of question.
In the book.
Richard Book would that be?
Ready for revolution.
In ready for revolution,
Stokely talks about coming to a realization
of the cultural constraints or the cultural...
Some of the challenges that women face joining may,
are the expectations of the day.
I was wondering when you would get to that.
Well, one of the things I find interesting is if I talk to people
with parts of student groups on different campuses,
that one of the things that they immediately run up against
is the curfew that women face because it made it more challenging
even to have plenty of meetings, same as sure.
And so I was wondering if you might talk about that a little.
Nug was always in gender terms,
a very well-integrated organization.
And the young women and nug were very, very faithful,
very committed,
and very hard workers.
They never really pushed for a leadership position
during my years here.
And we never thought to invite them into it.
There was never any policy or attitude as a woman
couldn't be leaders.
But there's a very articulate guys and a lot of women say
they were listening and learning.
And whatever else operated in the society to teach women
what's on the plates or at certain positions,
certain aspirations weren't appropriate to women,
they're obviously to a certain extent accepted.
But that was only in the positions of formal and public leadership.
I mean, I don't know any other woman who were shy about speaking up
when we have all long discussions about the side in policy,
where shy about leading demonstrations,
watching demonstrations,
where shy about expressing themselves almost,
it's almost African in the sense that there is an area
of jurisdiction, authority and control,
which is feminine,
and an area of control, authority and action,
and it's masculine.
It was sort of like that.
It was only in retrospect that I recognize the extraordinary price
that the O' Sisters paid for being as devoted to the struggle as they were.
So I'd meant that there weren't into homecoming,
and there weren't in-between kind of activities,
that there weren't into the accepted behavior of a whole-wood lady.
There weren't into the trivia of fashion and dressing up.
Though there were attractive women,
and it took care of them, says,
but there weren't the kind of trophy wives for the med school students,
and there weren't some of them might have been members of Greek-Late-Augnization.
But most of them, I suspect, weren't,
so that they occupied a place outside the conventional social norms
of the whole university student body.
So did the men.
But with men, I think,
we can't just say,
kiss my black ass.
I'm going about your business.
It wasn't so clear to me that a woman could do the same thing,
but like Mary Lovelace,
who came from a good bourgeois Mississippi family,
who's father-taught at Tougaloo, I believe,
and had met Stokey when he came out from the Freedom Rides,
she said,
we are here, natural,
and was damn near photo to the DOM.
It was Dean Patricia Roberts Harris,
who was the most progressive administrator at a university at the time,
who spoke up for her and interceded strongly in her behalf,
because there was host mothers who thought that they,
I'm lack of an aware here in nature,
was a disgrace to the race.
Would look like some disheveled, you know, Negro wench,
didn't look conformed to the appearance patterns of a Howard lady.
And they behaviors are to the end of the world,
as well as natural order were changing.
And Mary was not going to straighten her here,
and she wasn't going to use the DOM.
And finally, it got to Patricia Roberts Harris,
who was a dean of women, I believe,
or a dean of students, something like that.
And she interceded very strongly.
So that was the other aspect of Howard University.
You know, when we were struggling to get nag recognition,
for example, Bill Mahoney, who was a member of SNCC,
wrote an essay with the title,
Howard University, Colin,
Me, the Black Nor White, merely object.
And that was one part of our attitude.
I mean, going to struggle with the administration on various issues.
I never really understood that that was a struggling administration
had to make for public consumption.
But they never expelled any of us, as Southern University did.
And they never formally stopped us from doing what we're doing.
Through the administration, Howard University itself couldn't formally endorse it.
How did I get to that?
I asked you about the women in the A.
Right.
So that the price of assistance,
paid for being involved in this struggle,
was far more costly,
was for our heavier burden than the men had to pay.
And what I mean heard was,
you're going to get yourself a criminal record,
which rightful is going to hire you.
You're ruining your career.
That's not why you're here.
You know, paying attention to your schoolwork.
I remember there was one contemporary of always.
Always wore suits.
Always struck me as a very anxious Negro.
Always phoned him and everyone to visit the professor.
He was a doctor in his hand.
And clearly he was doing something I don't think.
And he always had some Student Nonviolent Coordinating Committee thought to do.
He was building a resume.
And he was said to be very smart.
But I can remember having a political conversation with this guy.
So I didn't exactly hold him in contempt,
but I didn't have any regard for him.
Really went to Harvard Law School, of course.
And if I say this, I'll probably identify him,
which I think was head on the New York Lawyers Association.
And I believe his underwater was underwater,
as a Harvard University.
So he went straight into the establishment.
And all pulled to him.
I guess in terms of American meritocracy,
this is regarded as a very productive life and career.
But on the other hand, Bill Mahoney was dropping out to school
to go work in the South.
It's child of the college dropping out to school.
I didn't tell him I said I don't think graduated.
Though he became a millionaire in the forest food industry.
After he got a big pacifist and core pacifist hang Thomas
got drafted by the military incentive here now.
And he went as a medic and came back.
So the price that a men paid were mostly in terms
of upwardly mobile career concerns.
The price that a woman paid was far more subtle and wide range.
It included that.
It also had to do with a concept of womanhood.
And what a black woman should be and should not be
that they had to struggle against, which we didn't.
Muriel Tillin has told me that when that was going on
with Mary Lovelace, it still clashed her
to wear her hair natural to support her.
Did she?
She said she did.
She had to figure out what it meant.
Muriel was very active.
And she was at an AACP.
And she told me at one point it was possible
to just some foreign trip for the officers of the AACP.
And the male students in the end,
those she was president or vice president,
the male students made up the delegation to go on this trip
and left the road.
And she went to Stokely Carmichael and said,
here's what Edwin Stokely Carmichael said, I think I'm going to stand
and Stokely Carmichael went and intervened in some force
everywhere.
And she went on a trip.
She told me that story.
Well, that's interesting.
But she told me that I think that her first connection
with Magd and she went on a demonstration
without really thinking it through or went through a meeting
or something.
I wasn't sure why.
And before she let that meeting so clear,
it said, well, we need you to do X, Y, and Z.
And she said, I had no idea how or what,
but he walked me through it and I did it.
And that was sort of how she described it in our action.
Well, women, you know, really came through.
I don't think any of us got to hold
when any extensive trend and radical
through it, the collectivism.
But that I mean, how do you write a press conference?
How do you get attention to the press?
How do you conduct a non-violent protest?
How do you deal with the police?
How do you negotiate them?
And you were on the administration?
We didn't come with that experience.
I mean, I tore you to that hack, Thomas.
And Cleve said, us came from resistant
and individual private ways in the Southern context
though to which they came.
But we did that up political skills very fast.
And I think that is what Muriel Tildinghaus
was telling you about her themselves.
And if you're talking about Hollywood,
it would be incomplete and inaccurate,
not to talk about the influence and effect of Tom Kahn.
Tom Kahn was white.
Tom Kahn was a socialist.
Tom Kahn was a radical, political activist
from New York from the time he dropped out
to high school at age 15.
Tom Kahn was gay.
Tom Kahn was a roommate and assumed lover of Bayard Rustin.
So he was in those political circumstances.
And I got a distinct impression.
I remember as a freshman senior, I walked into the dining
and comedy and there was a guy in a very Italian looking suit
that didn't look a murk and a talk to me.
Whose here was Don't You Are Shuller?
This is 1959.
I said to myself, that's a very strange looking white boy.
At first, there were very many white boys in there.
That was Tom.
I mean, back into a conversation about literature.
About Faulkner, I guess.
And here I am coming out to Jamaica.
So I do I know about Faulkner.
He looked at me and said,
I'm like, that's really, very perceptive.
That's really, very perceptive of you.
I said, well, thank you, sir.
As opposed to Bill Mahorn, for example.
Bill Mahorn also had here Don't You Are Shuller.
He looked like an Indian.
He would have been mistaken for a white guy.
He was working at a desk work study
in the Newman's residence hall when I walked in.
And he says to me,
tell me, sir, does the Kantian imperative also include
dialectical materialism?
Are you serious?
Those are the first words that came out to us both.
That's freshman.
So anyway, Tom came out to the Avo town.
And I had a distinct impression after I got to know him
and see how he operated.
That was a political decision in the socialist lift.
And then I said, okay, Tom, you should go to Hollywood
and try to guide the movement by a restful as a reactive
and non-violence and an socialist politics.
Tom was very active.
And he had all the skills.
He had more experience than we did.
So that is what happened.
You know, you talked about the price that women paid
in terms of their sense of womanhood.
That seems to come up with men in relation to nonviolence
and how that was perceived and how people fathomed with that at times.
Well, that history is a ugly head.
I used to go work in a factory some summers.
And I came back one fall out,
wearing this little kind of straw.
Cobo, I had pulled on this way.
I had wearing my jeans, my Cobo boots,
with my sleeves rolled up.
I made me a vest there.
Denim vest.
So there was a very mature image.
I never thought of it in those terms.
That's all I saw myself, you know.
And I went to my first demonstration and Tom jumped to me and he says,
where the hell you think you're going dress like that?
You're coming on here, this kind of mature,
posturing, you're going to invite violence.
I said, you mean my dress has to be non-violent?
What the hell you talk about?
And it didn't help much.
That is young blonde lady.
Perhaps one of the whitest leaders I've ever met.
Her name was Cynthia Jones, no deceased.
She was very pale, very blonde.
And apparently had some kind of interest in me.
So that whenever we're walking on these picket lines in Virginia or Maryland,
she would end up walking next to me.
And I kept saying, you know,
can she go walk with somebody else?
I really don't want to be lynched.
Which you couldn't come out and say that.
And remember she's walking next to me and I'm just saying,
God damn it, Cynthia, go walk someplace else.
Please.
But you didn't have too many white people in the demonstration anyway.
So you had to at least be a hospital, right?
And she said, I did giggling.
I said, what do you giggling about?
She said, did you hear what those kids said?
No. They said, may you go and get married and have polka dot kids.
Is it married or is it?
It didn't even hurt. It didn't much. It was me.
I guess not.
I didn't edit the side on, look like a daughter in Egypt.
And it seems to have some coherence, you know?
I said, I'm going to come looking for your house.
I'll give you a good one.
You ready to go, Dan?
So now I always had some white students from Surong and institutions
who would come in and demonstrate to those.
And I had a bride to such a person.
And then of course there was Paul Dietrich, who was the herd of both.
Very, very interesting guy.
And there was a day that Malcolm X gave to speak at home.
Now they said, you know, organized by biodiesel led to this coverage.
We couldn't bring Malcolm X.
We're organizing something called project awareness to get a certain kind of political discourse going on campus.
But the university administration had to deal with those red necks on the budget committee.
And he saw them congressmen.
So they couldn't allow certain activities.
And they couldn't endorse it.
So we coach project awareness and freedom of inquiry and this educational content.
And I can show you some stuff about it in a minute.
But when you're bringing certain controversial figures, you couldn't give them a platform.
But what could you do?
If you couldn't give them a platform, what could you do?
And you could just present them in a debate.
So you had to have the opposite position represented.
So for example, we got Herbert Aptheker, who was a chief theoretician of the Communist Party, U.S.A.
I've always wondered what the real job, the job description of a chief theoretician was.
But then he came, but when we brought him, it had to be a debate.
It's not a chairman of the socialist party, U.S.A. to discuss democracy and socialism and that kind of stuff.
So when Bayard Rustin came, no, when Malcolm came, it had to be in a Forman debate.
It couldn't just give this renegade racist, separatist, a platform.
So he had to debate Bayard Rustin.
Though talking about it with people like Ed Brown and people were there.
And I was seen back and adopted a bit that way.
He threw it through the fight.
He spoke briefly and profoundly about his position, about integration and work in class, black people,
alliances with the labor movement and integration of the society.
He spoke for about 10 minutes and shot it myself.
Because the minister has a more difficult position to argue, I will yield the rest of my time to him.
Said, I never give up this time to everybody.
So Malcolm just jumped in and said, I come to you in the name of everything that is eternal, the black man.
And who are Jens and young black students from the West?
He said before you were an American, you were black.
Before you were a Republican, you were black and you launched into this nationalist argument.
What the story I meant to tell about that?
Much later, when I went to Nigeria to give a talk, it was a six-year birthday celebration for Chinua Achebe.
A little guy, I was someplace, and I needed to get to some places.
And this little guy said to me, come, Professor, I'll give you a ride.
And I had to run out here with a professor of biology at Ensuka, the evil man.
He said, you don't remember me, do you?
He said, no, my brother, I really can't say.
I said, I was at home with you.
I'd miles with you on Stokely Carmichael.
I don't think he ever miles with us.
But he said, I remember when Malcolm came to the big, bad-hearted Rusted.
And so all of those names, that's why I met that international character of the student body.
And all of those things he remembered.
And the reason I said, I don't think he modeled for us is because foreign students really couldn't take part
in the political affairs of the country.
There was a stringent regulation about receiving that student visa that precluded them from doing so.
So there are a lot of Caribbean people from Trinidad, from British Ghana, from all over the other islands,
from Jamaica, who were there with me, who were equally affected by the winds of change.
Their territories are becoming independent.
They were inspired by the black movement in this country where black people were certain themselves.
And they were speaking supportive.
They would even come to meetings on campus, but they'd never go to demonstrations.
Because they were terrified that if they did, they would be deported.
So the audience, Malcolm, was speaking to us, comprised of this generation of black people from all over the black world.
And he was an extraordinary performance by Malcolm.
But prior to that time, some of our white allies, who would come to the demonstrations, were very excited.
Malcolm X was going to be turned upon campus.
You heard that story, right?
And myself, and I know Cortland was with me.
I was an editor of the student newspaper.
I was supposed to interview Malcolm and then take him to the dinner and then to the lecture to the bid.
And for some reason, we're supposed to meet in front of the girls' dorm.
At Ronser, we're all university campus.
We don't, we couldn't go into, by the way, with always conduct our business on the pavement in front of us.
And standing there with Cortland, waiting for Malcolm to come.
And when I look up there is Cynthia and Torres three other white co-eds running across who had always been under demonstrations running up to, as I said, with Jesus.
I was really embarrassed because I was embarrassed to see these white people.
Because Malcolm was coming.
And I was embarrassed to see them, I wanted to avoid them.
But I was embarrassed from that sentiment, from that feeling, which I thought was, you know, somehow dishonorable.
So I kind of smiled at his best that I could.
And he says, Malcolm, here he is.
Malcolm, here he is.
I said, no, I'm waiting here for him, you know.
And somehow they were standing in front of the dorm and I was facing them.
I'm a backwrested retreat.
And Cortland was standing behind them.
And he had said to me, as they came running up, you're going to go Malcolm to come and see his standing here talking to these devils.
And if they had been white men, it wouldn't have been so bad.
But you know, the whole notion of white women and the rest of that should, the rest of that stuff.
So I said, well.
And he said, we mean, you can make Malcolm come and see it talking to these devils.
And I said, look, the tried red.
I definitely call him by street name because I was trying to, because Malcolm minister nothing.
The tried red came and come on this campus and tell me who I should associate with or who I should talk with.
Who does the tried red think he is?
And I'm declaring no on my high horse, so to say.
And I'm looking in Cortland's eyes and Cortland is gradually getting pale and pale.
And he said, I think he's talking to me.
I mean, Cortland is a very dark fella, but he became a lighter shade of pale.
As he kept saying, I turn around and there is my accruem, the sunlight, glinting off his glasses.
And this looking at me with a tates, my love is fierce.
Mr. X, Mr. X, welcome to Howard University.
I'm the editor and supposed to interview.
Just looking at me like that.
But we had a very good interview because I tossed up white and journalistic pilots and we call it softball.
I mean, I said to him, is it true that your position is that the Negro is over this country and not really American citizens?
Can that really be your position?
After all, the native to this country says, my own brother.
Just because a cat has kittens in an oven don't make their muffins.
And I said, is it your position, sir?
Can it really be your position that black people shouldn't fight in the armed forces of the United States?
And he says, well, if I see a bunch of beers, have a bunch of wolves trapped in a cave.
Do you think I'm more fight for the wolves against the beers?
And he would always, again, as a very African means of communication, armed talk in terms of parables and extended metaphors and fables just like ASAP, whom you know what's an African?
Did you know that?
Yes, you know, Aesop's Fables.
But there's nothing that African animal tells.
He happened to end up a slave in Greece and these are African animals.
Malcolm had that same facility of speaking in allegories for never addressing the problem directly but indirect speeches that call it.
One time we were having a demonstration, we're marching to Robert Kennedy's office and we're carrying a coffin.
And the exact occasion of that day cannot remember.
But somebody had been murdered, some civil rights. That's right, that's why the coffin.
And we're going to replace the coffin and Robert Kennedy's desk asking for federal intervention.
I'll add it with the nice demonstration going. I'm a large margin that the fronters around with courtland and no courtland wasn't there.
Stokely and Edbrough and Cleve and Muriel and the rest of the liators.
And we're walking on a road and here's this tall, lanky filler with his arms crossed leaning against the lightposts with a very cynical and grun on his face.
Hey, that brother Malcolm, that's brother Malcolm.
So we let's the demonstration, we're running up to him.
This is after I interviewed him, I told him, right?
So I knew he recognized us all.
I said brother Malcolm, brother Malcolm, hold your echo demonstration.
He said well, credit demonstration was integrated, a lot of liberals had come out for it.
So if I see a land of rats and cats marching together into the same hole, you see if the cats asked me, how are we doing?
I say you're doing fine.
But if the mice asked me, how are you doing? I got the different answer to that.
We're just kind of deflated.
I said come on, you know, what's your problem here? What's your problem?
This because we haven't integrated demonstration.
He said, I mean, I said he's good, rightful, smart, and with us, did a good, right thing.
He said, am I to you something?
Because you see a mind throwing worms into the river, don't mean he afraid to fish.
Do you remember what you thought of him then?
I thought he was funny as could be.
Actually, I was going to say funny as I can go into the, I can go into the paint.
You can say anything.
Yeah, I know. Or the history hill.
We used to like him. We used to like his militants. We used to like his intelligence.
And I perceived that he was really trapped in the nation of Islam.
I mean, if you want to listen carefully to him, every time he had to, which he had to do very frequently, he had to hit that.
Yeah, Malcolm was an extraordinarily attractive, enigmatic, and complex figure to us.
Where we liked his militants, and we also liked his presence.
I mean, Malcolm would dominate any room he walked into.
And there was a quality of seriousness, gravitas, and an element of danger to Malcolm.
That was very attractive to us. That's a masculine thing you were talking about.
Any room that he walked into, he would dominate. It was just quite opposite to King.
If Dr. King was in a room, you'd ignore him. He had no physical presence to speak up until he opened his mouth.
And then once that was open, he would dominate it. But Malcolm was just sheer presence with.
So we liked that a bit. But we also perceived that he really had an activist spirit.
He really wanted to be involved in the struggle for black people, which he wasn't permitted to do by the ideology and theology of the nation of Islam.
And it became very clear to us that he was feeling that constraint.
And that was where he was standing by the side of the road looking at our demonstration.
And he had those fondly dismissive things to say.
But as we walked over from him, I had a sense that he looked very wistful standing there as we were marching after the Go Confront Bobby Kennedy.
Which was now much of a, Kennedy came out and spoke to us on the pavement in front of the Justice Department, as I recall.
But rather that Tom Con and Courtland had gone to sit in his office. So we had two people sitting in.
And by the time we got to Bobby Kennedy's office, two officers came out the front door, pushing the wheelchairs and sitting in the wheelchairs as Tom and Courtland.
And then as we leveled, we were in a source that had probably dragged them out to the, what, what, what, what.
And then we had the wheelchairs out to the office.
One of the twenty Louis Al in the middle.
Well, it was probably, that's probably the reason. That was probably the reason.
Within any event, reason for the demonstration.
But in any event, we noticed that when, I'm sorry, that when Malcolm had to recapitulate the ideology and theology and strange racial anthropology of the nation of Islam, he would always distance himself from it.
It looked like he was distancing himself. It looked like he was being trivited to the leader.
And he said, as the honorable Elijah Muhammad teaches us, as the honorable Elijah Muhammad teaches us.
And that would always, he'd prefaced everyone that was remarks that way.
And after a while, you hear it, you begin to say, as the honorable Elijah Muhammad teaches us. But then, so sure it makes no sense.
But that was the, on said portion, you know.
So we, Malcolm was an interesting guy.
Did you have any contact with him personally after he left the nation?
Yeah.
When I was at the Friends World College, I invited him to come to your house, I had his friends' world college business, out on Long Island, which is a strange experience.
I invited him to come speak, but that's when he was having his problems. And he couldn't come.
But he would move very nice letter, which unfortunately, I have a last.
There was one politically incorrect incident.
But he had a tell with it. It was not a record.
One of the reasons Malcolm was her own hold so much, her own Washington so much, she was organized in the Washington mosque, which had existed as a nation of Islam.
So it gave a reason to be there a lot.
For example, that project awareness thing, which I told you, we had to stage debates because we couldn't just bring people.
We had one very important event on the responsibility of the Black Rator.
And that influenced me personally a great deal.
Because John Oliver Killens, who son was at home, he came to speak, renovated Radfelus, and who followed it, impossible to be present, not surprising.
But James Baldwin came and Purlie Victorious, as a Davis came.
And again, it's just really hum kind who understood these kinds of things.
He said, well, you have to, I think, start in Brona, also, as well.
And where it's a student activity, it's project awareness. You should be the moderator.
So that was up there on the platform with all these important people.
I had never asked for that to a stahm who was saying, you know, because he was thinking of the politics, you got to have a student presence there and this kind of stuff.
And as we were walking out of the room, there are two figures who showed up.
And there's a guy with his hat kind of preload and trying to be anonymous and dark racist.
And to Scotland who said to me, hey, in that rather Malcolm, it was indeed Malcolm X.
I ran up to him and said, hey brother Malcolm, what are you doing? I said, I don't want to buy a rick now.
So what are you doing here?
Whenever James Baldwin was talking, whenever that little brother talks, I always come and listen.
And he was one of us, so towards Jimmy one time, you know, if I had to worry about this movement, you had to put it.
So he had a lot to respect for Jimmy and Jimmy had a lot to respect for him.
The other person who had come just to listen was sitting at the point here.
So I mean, it was a, you know, Malcolm was a wrong university, a wrong Washington, a lot to be saying.
Let's all come here on the street by the demonstration and stuff like that.
And had complained to buy it in point of fact.
That's why he had been invited to Oxford and he didn't invite it to Harvard, he had never been invited to Harvard.
So that's why that debate was set up for him.
Well, he was around organized.
And so one day he was there in the community, around 14 street, I guess, or youth street, was at street 14 then you.
And he was talking to brothers off the street.
So a group of us stopped by to hear.
And he was talking in some kind of a room.
It wasn't a hall or something.
And I'm not sure if there's a bar or whatever it was, but it was some kind of public space kind of thing.
Or maybe it was on the street corner, trying to remember the geography of it.
But there was an old clear black hustler.
Obviously Donan is locked.
Stinger Brimhant and various thread beer, hustler suit.
And obviously clearly quite drunk.
Older guy, much older.
And he was listening, and not enough, and listening.
And so as Malcolm is leaving surround the days, some of his nation of Islam, I mean, food of Islam or some of his supporters, or hustler say, young fella, young fella.
A lot of what you say, I agree with.
But some just don't hit me right.
So that's what I'm saying.
Well, first of all, I ain't giving up my pork chops.
Everybody started to laugh.
Well, everybody was laughing, but not sure how to do it in the presence of the stern Malcolm.
You know, laughing behind their arms and stuff like that.
And one more thing.
And Malcolm is really very tolerant.
And I'm like, what's that, my brother?
And he said, everything you say about the white man is true.
The white man here devil.
But the white woman, she had a job.
I said, oh, she had a job.
I say, obviously, no.
What profession that brother was fathered as the same as street pimping in his age?
White man here devil.
But the white lady, she had a job.
And I think Malcolm cracked this by, you know.
Can you tell me about non-violence and change?
Well, you know, at Howard, we really did see non-violence as a strategy, which was counter-intuitive.
And opposed to total personalities and sensibility.
First of all, most of the men, at least ones I was close to, were athletes of one kind or another.
I was a track man.
I even went out for football didn't last long, which I did.
One of the few was one of the only rest of the students that wrote for football.
That's about two weeks.
And, you know, I used to box me that I'd grown a lot.
So that we were physical.
And in my own culture, just like the African American young men, notion of certain matters of honor,
what you had to do was fight.
So non-violence was not an any way natural towards our normal towards.
And one of the biggest stick-and-points was if somebody came and attacked a sister.
And if it was something I worried about a lot.
And, you know, to come up in discussion, I say, you know, the Tom, for example, who was a committed pacifist.
You know, if you know his career, he went on to work for the labor union.
He became very profil in the AFL-CIO.
And had a real role in solidarity to the Polish labor union at World Communism.
Tom was shuffling funds back and forth, going to Poland all the time, carrying money for solidarity, you know.
So he was a committed labor next to SkanaGa.
But he was also a pacifist and he was gay.
And I say, you know, what we're going to do if somebody used crack as attacked the sisters?
I mean, I don't know if I'm going to be non-violent. He says, well, if you declare yourself a conscientious object
or wonder the classical questions, the traditional questions when they interrogate you.
And he goes, what if your younger sister was attacked by a racist?
Would you stand by and be non-violent?
And he says, and so he would give, which he didn't use him greatly.
And he said, no sir, I would non-violently interpose my body between her and the attacker.
And he said, that's what you do.
If it's a gets attacked, throw yourself over her, don't attack the other person, come between them to stand there and take the blows.
And so that's what I resolved there with doing that circumstance.
It never ever happened to me.
But the real problem I had, written on violence, was under Washington demonstrations.
And one has to be clear now.
The conditions which prevail in the South were inconduceive to non-violent practice.
Non-violent practice is theatre. Non-violent practice is psychological warfare.
Biot was extraordinary practitioner of that because he was so dramatic.
And what you do is you control the discourse.
You control the behavior of the so-called attacker, even though you never attack him.
Biot has an ethical non-violence versus Jim Crow, which shows you how that operates.
The questions you ask, the things you say, the behavior you do.
Even though you might be beaten, there's no question who's controlling the encounter.
But that requires a small enclosed place.
It requires witnesses.
It's the media zero, the cameras so much the better.
But in a dark country road, or if you're sleeping in your house, there's no technique of non-violence that can protect you against a sniper or somebody coming to bomb the house.
So you need to understand where an unviolence operates and where it doesn't.
Now in the DC operations, that was an arena for non-violence.
And the media was there in front of the White House, in front of the Capitol, in front of the Horde University.
So you behave in a certain way and you let the mob and the resident behave in their own way.
And you psychologically, politically, can win this by controlling the image.
At all demonstrations, there was one group who would invariably show the American Nazi party.
With George Lincoln Rockwell in his town troopers, uniform walking around the place, smoking cigarettes and a cigarette wholor.
And as followers, the members of the Master Race wearing swastikers and khaki and stuff like that.
But that used to really annoy me.
Because what it cops would do is we would have a picket line and they would force them to have their own picket line.
And they would walk around the place where there were racist sands and swastikers.
Which was particularly troubling if it was a core demonstration in so many of them were.
Because most of the core members were professional people, intellectual people, white people.
There were not an essentially intellectual pacifist group.
And a great many of their members were Jewish.
So that...
And the other thing that bothered a hell out to me was that these representatives of the Master Race,
didn't seem to be in good physical condition.
Some of them were fat, some of them were pot-bedded, some of them were certified in the seals.
It looks fairly retarded, unshaving, walking around the place of the Master Race.
Where we were relatively fit, clean cut student types.
But there was a certain point at which the two lanes would come fairly close.
There would be a cop standing, you'd walk around the cop.
So there would be a cop standing there.
But there would be, you know, my five or six yards.
So when you got there, you were turning.
A member of the Master Race in the swastikos and stuff.
We're looking at you and me, good, this and me, good, and next.
And you're saying crack downward, kick your ass under your breath, so you turn around.
And I kept really wanting to, and I said, you know,
if these suckers would just end their...
The demonstrations would end at the same time.
I said, if they just hang around the place, so we could meet them on the way back to campus, walking back to campus.
Now we could really see who was the Master Race.
Which was a fairly naive form of machismo and magpaw.
We can't talk much about a real fear of fate like we used to have.
Not even a gang fate.
These guys obviously had clubs, had probably guns and knives and stuff.
It would be a nasty fate, it would be ugly.
But...
Oh, position was, my position was.
As long as we're not on a formal demonstration,
where we had been necessitated for the discipline and unviolence.
If I catch you crackers under way back to school,
we were really soon who was the master, you know.
But fortunately, it never happened.
I believe they got their guys and went back to Maryland, over to January, over to headquarters,
where they soon as the demonstrations are over.
But on the other hand, in Mississippi, we were in unviolence,
because they were not, many demonstrations.
And it's day-to-day business of organizing the crisis of unviolence
never be clear in that much of an issue.
Except when Charlie Cobb and Mendy Samstein Samstein said
that they were in theoso and the local leaders.
Bernard just missed a step to who's hosted, was in,
Amzie Moore.
And they said the clan was raiding.
And after supper, whoever was hosted was,
the farmer's whose host was had a couple of sons.
And after supper, he took on a shotguns and the rifles,
and he gave one to each of his sons.
He took one and said they were getting ready in case of a line of attack,
and to defend the host.
And then they asked Charlie Cobb and Mendy Samstein,
y'all want to go.
And that was the common from the brought to the meeting.
They said, well, why should we have done?
We're supposed to be non-violent.
Well, if the people whose guests we are defending their homes
and their offers are going to retake it or not.
And that was one of the first discussions after I went to a sneak meeting
in the south.
And that discussion was the last three, four hours.
And as I say, we, in NG,
were non-violent, only strategically.
People from Nashville, for example, John Lewis
and brother from Mississippi, what's his name?
And Diane Nash and people like that were non-violent.
Like, war was non-violent.
As a religious spiritual conviction.
So that was attention.
I'm just, it's not something to me recently about getting a stomach
and still clearly, clearly,
clearly, I'm asking, clearly,
clearly, you know, thinking about that?
I've heard it.
And directly.
I think Stokey was sent to get the guns out.
Somebody had some guns in there.
And Bob Moses could go and recall it,
and I get emote it from your host.
So there wouldn't be found.
But to cut back to the discussion in Student Nonviolent Coordinating Committee.
So some of the people like Nash,
we're non-violent, we're non-violent.
Absolutely we can carry guns.
This is totally antithetical to us.
Forget Nettwin Bayard Rustin went down to Martin Luther King's host
in Montgomery.
He almost sat down and are going sitting on the chair, you know?
And that, especially the leadership,
the activist group of the Black community,
would not just them,
had a traditional hand to defend themselves
and neither the law nor the state was going to protect them.
So they had to protect each other.
Like Hartman Turnbow, I took over,
going on, I commenced the puppet.
I commenced the puppet.
So there was a long discussion in the meeting.
And finally people concluded they said,
look, the organization is non-violent.
With individuals are necessarily non-violent all the time.
If you are in somebody's home,
and their home is in danger of being attacked,
and they decide to defend their home and you,
and they offer your weapon to do so,
whether you take a knife or not is not Student Nonviolent Coordinating Committee's business.
That is a personal decision you have to make.
If you feel comfortable sitting there,
and other people do your fight, and for you,
then you do that.
If that's what's your non-violent means,
what Student Nonviolent Coordinating Committee has no position to know what you're doing
in that circumstance.
And that seems struck me as an imminently intelligent and smart
way to resolve the discussion,
so that impressed me a great deal of both Student Nonviolent Coordinating Committee.
The first time I went south,
it was to Mississippi,
and it was to a Student Nonviolent Coordinating Committee meeting in Weveland.
That was an interesting story.
That was an interesting...
The first time so.
Yes, ma'am.
No, that was my second time soath.
The first time soath I drove.
Well, I didn't hear that story, too.
We're driving down Naggar,
and Naggar was driving,
as he always insisted on doing.
Quarter or zero?
Kleeve's set us was here,
we drove through South Carolina
and stopped at Kleeve's house,
and his mother and father fixed a great feast for us,
and our mother Kleeve was in a car.
I don't know if you'll let him hold towards.
Bill Mahoney was,
the guy we had said at the Student Nonviolent Coordinating Committee offices,
and he said it though,
her name is a talkable,
that's Nick Conference.
Um...
I would go now,
or it must have been in South Carolina,
and Naggar,
I have to get rid of the hell we were,
and it was the dead of night.
And people were hungry,
but they're driving past these roads,
and they're driving restaurants like Howard Johnson or the rest of...
I'd be going to your anticoot,
no stuff,
I was in the car,
I said,
if I was to your arrogance,
I'd say, you know,
if you're going to be free,
you have to act free.
I mean, are you driving past these damn restaurants?
Let's go in there and order some food.
And I say,
shut up there,
but you're not here at all.
I'm going to go to the restaurant,
so these guys had been before.
And since talk is cheap,
I was reading the book,
and I had to look up.
I'd say,
you know, you're driving past another restaurant.
I mean, let's stop and get something to eat.
You're going to starve yourself today.
If you're free, act free.
All of a sudden,
I could jam down the brakes,
and screech in the street.
Go!
It jails into a plaque and like.
I said,
all right, make a act free.
In the dead of night.
So I looked her own.
No matter what,
look up me.
I had brought a fafft here,
and I was never riding in there.
No matter what they look at me.
All right, I'm going to act free,
so I jump her to the car,
and walk up to her restaurant.
I said,
I brought her to the lights.
Then I had seemed to get brighter and brighter.
And I walked in there.
These were Southerners.
I'd never seen Southerners before.
They were all sunburned.
They were working class looking.
People had on carcass,
our jeans,
and big hats on cowboy boots.
And I mean, I didn't even have looked at me.
But there are some people who did.
And I had the feeling that all the conversation
in this bright little restaurant
had come to a stop.
And the people were looking at me,
and I was absolutely terrified.
And I said,
I could walk out,
and you know,
said I wouldn't serve me.
And I said,
I ain't going to do that.
So I sat down
at the booth,
not at the window light.
And nobody came to serve me.
And I think people are looking at me.
And I'm getting more and more and more terrified.
And I'm saying,
I can't walk,
I got to make a stand some kind of me.
And I'm going to my own service.
What the hell am I going to?
Who you get to say
if you're in a situation
where you don't just walk
or to the police,
and say, they're terrified?
And when I looked
at the window,
there was a guy in the back of the window.
It brought his next three,
and I thought,
they all had spent the battery
and it was going to happen to me.
I don't know if they were going to rush
and to see if it should happen.
I was thinking,
what's back to the car?
But I said,
come on, come on.
And so I was very happy
to get to go walk
or hear if they were going to try
and go drink.
I was so glad to see those guys
standing near looking at me.
I hadn't totally abandoned me.
You know, I missed that my big mouth.
I put me in.
And so we get to the car
and there's a long silence.
And I don't really want to say,
gee, I was so glad to see you guys.
I was so glad you were doing it.
But they all quiet,
but smile, you know.
I said,
you're tied up acting free, you know,
with that word?
I said, you are, I shut up.
But I was grateful to see you, you know.
It's been terrified of yourself, yet.
Yeah, it's fine.
But I remember,
we got to Atlanta.
And when I got up there,
I wanted to walk towards
it in the black community.
And there were these little hoses
with a little raised gardens.
And what was amazing about the land was black,
and they had shells around their flowers and stuff.
And some of the flowers
were the exact same flowers
I had seen at my grandmother's house
in the hills of West Maland.
And I had an immense rush of nostalgia
because under way the beds were organized.
Those were organized very much like my grandmother's bed.
So I had not thought about for 25 or 30 years.
It just came Russian back at me.
The next time I went to, as a story I have always meant to write and never did.
The next time I went south to a sneak meet in, I didn't have to drive.
I called up and said, third, what I needed you down here earlier.
I said, well I'm driving down with the brothers and thirds there, meetings Friday.
He said, no, no, no, no.
You come on Wednesday and I'm going to send you a plane ticket.
I said, well, I had just gone on to the SNCC staff.
You know, Jim was pretty much a chief executive.
So I said, well, I felt really important to see you, I wanted to slide on where he needs
me, what else is going on.
So I didn't drive, then I got on the plane and I flew down to Atlanta.
And Forman meets me, our sense of why to meet me and drive me up to the SNCC office
and takes me into our office.
There's a typewriter and there's a tape recorder.
I'm very flattered that Forman nurse wanted me, don't worry.
He said, look, there you have a tape, a history of SNCC.
I need a speech for the meeting on Friday.
Can you do that?
Obviously, somebody I told him I was a writer.
Very flattered.
I said, we're happy to do so, Jim.
And it was an amazing tip.
And he talked about when SNCC first was formed and he came in as executive secretary,
who he didn't have any money.
How certain barbecue giants would see the young woman.
How certain hairdressers would do they hear for them?
How the community would support them?
How do you remember it from one of the early projects that caught them?
I said, they needed a gestetner.
And there was no money to get that.
And he said, that's still in the office.
I'm tears came to my hands.
I said, in this big, rich country, these young people need just a guest titan
machine and I can't get it from them.
I resolved to get it for them.
And the narrative was a narrative of his building up the base of support by this time.
SNCC was really affluent, right?
I mean, not really.
Other organizations were from that homebilt start.
We only had one telephone in the office and that was because what's her name was
being for it from our YWCA fellowship.
Not in the speaker?
Connie Curry.
Connie Curry was paying for it.
We were really first came to the office.
There was one telephone and one box of papers in there.
And that telephone was only there because Connie Curry was paying for it.
There were YWCA fellowship.
And the office was only there because SCLC gave him this one room.
I know we had this office on Raymond Street and we're all national organization.
And so the text, the narrative that he had put on tape was incidents from his building
and that and his thoughts and stuff like any wanted it for a speech.
The question is why did he want it for a speech?
Because,
Jean Wheeler.
Frank Smith.
Frank Smith has raised an insurrection to the poor, the leadership in the Atlanta office.
And Jim was about to fight back and he wanted this speech as a kind of this campaign signature.
So I made quite a lovely speech.
It's very moving in material, you know.
Especially for that audience, the growth of the organization and the heroism of the early people in it.
So I fashioned it into quite an effective speech.
And at the end, Jim once said, you know,
why I think we need to do, why I think we owe to the movement is to take care of our health.
I haven't taken as good care of my health as I should have.
So I know I have to go to a hospital for a couple weeks of recuperation, but I will be back.
And he said that I will be back in a couple weeks, but I know the organization will continue and flourish.
Continue to be a band of brothers and a be unbroken".
It is circular beyond growth.
That's how I ended the speech, right?
So the night before that meeting, I go into the staff is coming in from all the various projects.
And I really used to like, I do still do, you know, black, southern culture, new oral tradition and the music.
And people know that.
They used to come and go with funer-talk and Mike Thelva.
Here come all the funer-talk and Mike Thelva.
This page is mentioned in the accent.
So people were playing cards.
Pinochloroite was the play at various tables.
I go to all the tables and the southern staff.
Like I would see that good sister from Alabama who you secaried.
And it hurt.
And it hurt every and the peacock brothers at one table.
I go up and say, you know how much I love the culture and the way you guys sing.
And I say, there's a song that I just have a feeling that I want to hear.
May the circle be unbroken".
You like that song, oh, Mike?
I say, yeah, Mike, could you sing it for me please?
And it's the song that I'd sing.
And I said, thank you.
And now the table, there's every Jess and Maris.
And I've got a lot of other people.
And I go over here and say, you know, there's one of the songs that my brothers and sisters sing.
That they really love extra nearly a bit of surre to be unbroken.
You think he could sing that for me.
And then you heard four men's speech ended.
And I was kind of priming the audience for the speech, right?
So I got about five or six tables to indulge my sentiment to the love of this song.
I got them singing the night before me.
And I was kind of primed.
All the meat and political meat and I've ever really rigged, right?
So the morning Jim gets up and he launches into the speech which I had structured for him.
And he was very moving and he talked about, you know,
how they had nothing when they started and how they built the organization and the alliances and contacts he had made.
Oh, I forgot to tell you.
Because I had gone to Atlanta and worked with him.
I didn't drag straight down to Waveland to the limits.
You know, we fly down.
So we got an airplane.
Did we fly down to Waveland?
Forget whether we flew. Maybe I drove down with Jim, okay?
However we got to Waveland and when we were driving into the parking lot, there was a soldier in a fleet.
And you know, who we got those?
Was it a donation from UAW?
It wasn't a donation, but it was a...
The UAW organized the auto industry.
So that one of the things that negotiated with them was the ability to buy cars for cost price.
Now those cars were selling for $2,000, $2,500, $3,000.
What it cost? $500 to make.
And that's the price that ERAW would pay to the auto workers for them.
So the ERAW bought cars for us. It's $500 a pop.
So we had to use new (UAW-donated) imperialism.
There were really great cars. The southern staff, the organization staff really loved them.
And as we drove into the parking lot,
I remember now that the text and substanceage in the speech was the polygiotoe, which you had come,
he said, sojournal motor fleets.
He was just trying to draw all these guys and puffing up this chest.
You know, so it was really...
So anyway, first the other meeting Jim gets up.
And he delivers the speech.
And as I said, it's a very moving speech.
And he gets to the conclusion.
He talks about to have to protect our health.
He's going to the hospital, but he promises he will be back like MacArthur.
He will return.
And he says,
and Student Nonviolent Coordinating Committee will go on,
a band of brothers,
and a be unbroken".
He has a be unbroken".
And he turned away from the microphone that Dr. King used to do.
And from all over the hall,
I used a be unbroken".
Band by, band by.
And it was so freaking moving that I started to cry.
And I said to myself,
said, well, you can't stand in the room and be crying in a situation that you yourself have organized and set up.
And I came crying at the meeting that you own rigged.
So I ran out.
So I ran out to the room, right?
To grow up on the tree.
And then somebody else ran out to the meeting and they were crying too.
And it was Frank Smith, the insurgent.
And Frank Smith said,
thanks, Barbara.
You done just treated me.
And I said, Niggur, you crying just like me.
It's a story I've always made to write.
I'm wondering about his bandit Aaron,
who cut the sentence,
surgeon to where the organism against.
He was so touched by the speech that he was outside of the room crying too.
I remained in Frank of that and he never denied it.
What was Frank organizing the insurgency?
He wanted to become chair at the poster gym.
He wanted to play a gym from the chairmanship.
And I don't remember what issues he had,
but he was traveling to all the various projects
and talking that kind of stuff enough to get Jim alert and a little bit anxious.
You know, I've seen versions of that speech.
And the page,
would you like a coffee?
Sure.
Is it as moving as I recall it?
I've actually seen the speech,
or if I've seen part of the larger story,
you know, the history of Smith,
but it describes those early days.
I really look like I'll send it to you when you tell me.
I think I've seen a couple of versions.
So one of them might be the actual speech that you construct in Hollywood.
Right. There's a good narrative of a description of that meat,
and I would like to see it.
But it's how I remember it, January.
I never, but see when I was reading these,
I was guessing that it was from Hollywood or for a wave one,
but I didn't know.
And so I've never heard the story.
The story of context, then.
Yeah.
So Frank, can you forgive you?
Yeah, I mean,
I mean, he didn't say it in the angry way.
I mean, he was cranchot, you know.
We're both very moved.
Yeah.
Well, not a people in that meat to her crying, actually.
I know.
So the emotional meat.
But after Jim's speech, I mean, at the end of that speech.
And when that spontaneous raise the song,
raise the circle, be unbroken.
I said, yeah, yeah.
Then I ran out to the meat.
But in a few days,
a few days, a few days,
there was another point,
in that movie where it felt like things were just coming apart.
And Jean had been teaching her a song.
And I asked her,
as, you know, she's like, come on.
And now, we need to sing.
It's a different meeting.
It was a different meeting.
That was a meeting,
Oh, some of projects.
when they broke into song and saved the meat and that's the meat and I think.
I think, well, I know what you're talking about.
Well, that's at least one error. Maybe there was another one.
I think she said it was another one. There was a different song.
But you remember?
The one that Oxford that was freedom that I say as a constant.
They said that freedom is a constant sorrow on the earth.
Which is a very haunting song.
So I should since we're talking about Waveland, I should probably ask you about the notorious Waveland.
Yeah, your brother Stokely Carmichael's comment.
That's thoroughly discussed in that book.
I know it is, but maybe not everybody will unfortunately not everybody will need the book and you could do it for a different.
I really, I really, really.
So let's start with, um, so you said the, the, the SNCC conference at Howard was your first?
It's the same thing. You're right.
My first political lesson is he went form and decided to set up a SNCC office and the nag people suggested that I should have the job.
I didn't have anything to do and I just graduated. So it was great.
They wanted a Washington representative.
The polite term, the impolite term for which is lobbyist and somebody who could maintain the interest of snake before the national media in Washington.
And then the halls of Congress and, you know, to the white host, we could get there.
So they wanted a prison in Washington, which is, which is what every national organization wants.
So the first just sent, and Bill Mahoney was sent up from the source to come work with me.
We're both cool directors of the office.
And I remember going, a new bill, I remember, you asked me about the, can't you an imperative and boxing dialectic enough, first met him.
So I knew he was a strange fellow, but I didn't know how strange should I went to meet him at the bus station.
He comes off the bus and he has a box, a wooden box and a cardboard box.
And the wooden box, she had any number of philosophical textbooks.
And then the cardboard box, she has a drawers, a pure dungaries and one shirt.
That was his complete wardrobe, apart from what he was wearing.
So he came and we set up the office, right?
And the first assignment was, we want to have a conference in Washington so that the staff can learn what federal programs there are and what can be done.
And how to access them and how they can use them in the interests of the community.
So get all the people from the department of agriculture.
You want people from the justice department.
You want people from the department of housing.
The whole range of federal bureaucrats is supposed to get to come to these meetings.
Which we succeeded in doing.
And this mixed field staff and the local people would come up and we have these conferences.
And we have a meeting with the local people that was at home.
I don't know what documentation you're phone on that.
And this was my first chance to meet all this.
And then the northern staff was coming to people from New Jersey, from Massachusetts, from New York.
So it's my first chance to be in a row and all these sneak people.
You know, extraordinary bright and attractive young people.
It was really a great congregation to be in.
But after, like the first day, like all the conferences, after the first day,
there were rumors for everybody who's present.
And then when the federal bureaucrats started to come in and talk about these programs,
the meetings got smaller and smaller and smaller.
And the federal bureaucrats, as well, as I was very distressed, that a conference was being successful.
And at a certain point it got very lit and people were tired.
And Bob got up and said, all right, looks like people are tired and they're losing attention.
We need some energy.
Mrs. Hamer, come and talk to the people.
And it's the first MFDP first to Hema.
And she got up and talked about how she went to register.
And then she started to sing.
And the whole room started to sing.
And it was my first real introduction to the Southern spirit of the movement.
Because Mrs. Hamer was the exemplification of Southern black culture and the best of it.
It was a very, very, very, very powerful occasion for me, which I had.
And I was very excited to see the first time I heard Mrs. Hamer,
and I went to the very, very powerful occasion for me, which I have never forgotten.
And that's when I met most of this next staff.
But ultimately, the conference was judged to be very successful and people got the information they needed.
And I got my first political lesson from Jim, because to do this conference,
we have to get resources.
So I'm going around the place to all the labor unions, all the liberal political organizations,
which really was my job.
I mean, most people who send lobbyists to Washington send them with big bankrolls,
so they give, give them out stuff to people.
So I was going to only place asking people for stuff.
So I really recognized Blackpaw in those terms when it came.
We no longer have to be supplicants.
We got to take something to the meetings.
We got to have something to trade.
We got to go into the meeting with some nut or so I had to know our hands.
Because like the meeting, I told you about with the Catholic Bishop, who told me he had just been in Argentina,
and the ceremony was expensive and it's a ring costume so much.
And really was that the movement was going to white organizations seeking support,
almost as a charitable dispensation.
And I wasn't having any all that great success going to the usual suspects as it were.
And then I went to an unusual suspect who was persona and non-grasher,
and outside of organization, the teamsters.
And the teamsters gave me a thousand dollars, which was a lot of money, to me anyway.
And the first contribution I had really got and said to someone, I said, Jim,
the teamsters have said they would give us a thousand dollars.
But can I put that name in the program as one of the sponsors?
Because, you know, you have supposed to deal with them.
And Jim says, Mike, you can't sleep with them at night and refuse to walk
going to the street to them in the morning.
So the teamsters was right at the top of all the sponsors.
When you're trying to find money for that conference, and if you're doing this circuit
and having those conversations, did anybody talk about the issue with the Furt?
Well, not the founding conference, but the one in October 1961,
fired was invited and then uninvited because of AFL, CIO, money.
No. Who would have talked about that?
I didn't know if they knew what the new organization, I mean, Jim knew about it.
He wasn't there for it.
Julian Bond somebody who was around for it.
Yeah, but I was asking people in Washington for funds.
Nobody, right? Nobody briefed me on that.
No, no.
So did you look at how they get back to that Washington liberal establishment
before all businesses here at Sfinish did it?
So when you, so you opened that office, the SNCC DC office,
and like what, fall 1963 then?
I would say so.
And then that conference, I know I think it was like right after Kennedy was assassinated.
Right, so that didn't even want November.
So I'm not going to go with that.
Oh, right.
So the Thanksgiving conference, right?
And at that point, did you know that you were going to be working on the FTP challenge?
Or was that so?
The FTP didn't exist.
I'll consider that was still there.
It's the working out of the details of the program.
The FTP didn't exist.
One of the first other responsibilities we had was when Bob Moses to Washington, Bob Moses,
and said that they were planning to Summer Project.
So my project was when six, six, three, or six to four.
All right, but this was in fall 1963.
So in the spring, in the spring of 1964, Bob Moses and said,
he had made this discussion decision after discussions with Robert Spike and the rabbis
and everybody.
And on the state with these Norman volunteers, because the movement had come to a stalemate.
And what had been happening, all the killings that had taken place up to that point,
were of local people.
Because I think there was a policy not to kill the volunteers, because Ada had congressmen of North.
And Bob Moses with a foreign number to the Justice Department.
And besides which the volunteers, this Nickwork, they're outside as an odd and as couldn't
vote.
So they're concerned about the suppressed vote.
As it still is to this very day, suppressed the vote in the black community.
And how you do that, you kill the people who can vote, you kill the leaders, and intimidate
the rest.
So, and it was after the murder of Louis Allen that I think Bob decided to have this summer
project and bring in people to break that logger.
So my job was to take him around the place to all these pockets of progressive thought and liberal
influence, ADA, this kind of stuff.
That think tank, over there on Wisconsin Avenue, at the Watts School, what was that?
Partisans studies, Institute for Partisans studies, right?
Places like that.
And I was taken by my own.
And I think this meeting was at the Institute.
And there are a lot of progressive congressional ids.
There are a lot of young people, I mean, they call the people together from the Institute.
They wouldn't have had all those contacts.
A lot of people in the labor union who are said to be progressive, center of progressive thought.
And Bob said, well, what we're thinking of doing is creating a political party after the freedom
vote which led just ahead.
Call the Mr. Be Freedom Democratic Party and we're going to go to the convention in Atlantic City
and challenge your regular Democrats.
People say, wow, what a dramatic idea, what a brilliant idea, what a bold idea.
But how is it going to be doing?
That's what required credible organization.
Where the resources are going to come from.
Can your organization, such a party, and survive?
All of these were very intelligent kind of doubts and questions.
And besides which, the National Democratic Party will never tolerate you in Atlantic City.
So it's exotic, it's doomed to failure.
And so they're going back and forth.
Well, maybe we would support such a thing.
Well, what is Johnson's and Johnson was the uncrowded king of the political world at that time.
I haven't taken over after Kennedy and done so well.
What's LBJ going to say about it?
What's the Democratic party going to say?
You'll never be seated in Atlantic City as quick as I think.
And that was a tenor of the conversation and then Bob said.
And then somebody said, you know, if you really want to get a read on it,
you better discuss it with Joseph Rauh.
And Bob said, well, I just left Joseph Rauh's office.
And Joe said we could be seated.
What?
Joseph Rauh said what?
He said Joe said we could be seated.
He thought we could be seated.
Who will move in the meeting?
Well, if Joseph Rauh said that, then maybe there's a possibility.
Maybe we better look at this thing again.
And then people started to make commitments of support.
Just under basis of Bob saying that Joseph Rauh said we could have been seated.
Because he was a very powerful, beltway politician in the internal politics of the Democrats.
And the liberal forces in Washington, B.C.
I remember that very distinctly.
And then we started to organize and support for the challenge.
I mean, not for the challenge for the summer project.
We started recruiting people.
And we recruited a lot of people from the active, but only in the summer project.
And the story of Stokely and Courtland B[and back?].
It came through the office.
And we recruited Ralph Featherstone Featherstone.
Now Feather, one of the things the office used to do was to raise food and clothes for the people who were kicked off the land.
And from the ceremony and suburbs and from the supermarket to the SNCC coffees ones,
safe way and stop and shop and place a leg there.
And we gathered these food and these clothes.
We'd saw it at the clothes and we'd get boxes and boxes of food, can food and stuff.
And we'd send them down in a truck.
And it teams this would send one of their drivers to drive the truck down for us.
And they would almost also help us get the half track to do it.
So that was one of the activities of their office.
And this was being done.
And we went to talk about the the high school friends of SNCC coffees.
You ever heard of the the high school friends of SNCC coffees?
You should.
That woman who organized the anniversary conference, Charlene Crines,
was one of the the high school friends of SNCC coffees.
And there were young white people who lived in the suburbs,
whose people were probably employees of the federal government or professional people.
And there were a great group of high school kids who I really loved them.
We put them to incredible.
We had some little schemes that we used to work.
Couldn't knew that in Washington anymore.
All right.
So they used to come in.
They used to help collect the food and clothes.
They used to help make the appeals to various people.
We'd appeal to churches.
We'd appeal to schools.
And everybody would have a collection.
We'd collect it.
Come to the office.
We'd saw it.
We'd send it.
One of the people who shared our office was a committee for miners
led by a Scotsman named Hamish Sinclair.
But their Washington representative was a young guy named Joel Drexler.
And we get him spacing the SNCC coffees coffees guy didn't have them.
And this was when, in Hazard, Kentucky,
there was a huge miners strike against the coal miners and stuff like that.
And one day, Joel decided he was going to bring a group of miners
people active in the strike.
And about 10 or so of these hillbillies came.
They were talking about the high sheriff,
like the high sheriff of Nottingham.
I mean, some of their language was Elizabethan, you know.
And they talked about hills and dails and down in the hotter.
And stuff like that is so enough Scots there is hillbillies.
And I really like those guys.
They asked me to come and start the SNCC coffees project in Hazard, Kentucky,
which I took to Foreman, but said no dailies in the property just as well.
Look, I never shoot them.
And when they came in, I said, OK, Joel, I take them to dinner.
And there's a black restaurant.
And I was supposed to be the most fancy black restaurant.
I called it Keys Restaurant.
There were a new street in Washington.
And it took them there.
And we went inside to eat.
And we're at the table.
And I said, you guys can have a drink on Student Nonviolent Coordinating Committee.
The guy ordered a Salisbury steak, mashed potatoes and some green peas.
And he was meal Kim.
And it sat in front of him and he just looked at it.
And a tear I'm doing is cheek.
And I said, I didn't know what was going on with the guy.
I said, all right, something wrong.
He said, now it's just like this, the best mess I've had in two years.
Best mess is what he called it.
And he was, you know, so when they left, I said,
the people in Mississippi were one mind where I said, Lord up their van.
We had as much food from the drive to Mississippi as we can't spear.
And we just loaded the top.
Lots of canned beans and stuff like that.
And sent them back to hazard Kentucky.
And they allowed us how it would be a good thing if Student Nonviolent Coordinating Committee was a considerable project there.
But that never went very far.
Did some white workers go into hazard a couple of years later down the road
working with Anne Braden, maybe?
If so, I don't know anything about it.
What Student Nonviolent Coordinating Committee did to start the project here?
And if we were going to start the project, but at that time we didn't have the White folks project.
But if we're going to start the project, that'd have been hope to do it, you know?
I think he eventually won the legacy of the White folks project when it didn't go to the show.
I did a bit.
I did a bit some years down the road.
So the high school friends of Student Nonviolent Coordinating Committee used to come in to sort and package and pack up the food and clothes to grow.
But there were a bunch of screenture high school students, you know?
Well, me and Anne, I love them all.
I said, oh, you all got to get this to organize.
And this black guy who was teaching school came in and said, he wanted to see what he could do.
I said, he's where you can do take control of that bunch of rascals over there and get them organized to get his food and clothes going to Mississippi or people needed.
And he took control and he organized them.
And he had a way of reasoning with them.
He had a way of being firm with them.
But obviously I explained it organized.
I would have certain quiet authority to him.
You know who I'm talking about, right? It's Ralph Featherstone Featherstone.
And Feather was organized, many truckloads of food and stuff to Mississippi and then came to some project.
And Feather, he was married.
And he was a little bit older.
He had been a all city point guard high school player.
He had graduated from college and he was teaching school.
I think in a middle school or something like that.
And he said to him, Mike, I think I want to go to Mississippi on this project.
I said, Feather, you married.
And unlike the rest of the Smith people, you know, it's a young man who would start his career.
He had a teaching job.
I said, let's go talk.
So in the office, I always sat in the curb looking at the FBI guy.
That was always by across the street.
And I said, Feather, you know, there's a hell of a good chance that everybody who goes down here, he'd come in back.
And he said, my people and my people struggle.
And if that's the way it goes, that's the way it goes.
I said, all right, brother.
He accepted.
And he left to go to the orientation in Oxford.
And on the way, don't dismiss the FBI after the orientation after sharing the Goodman and Chaney (and Schwerner) disappeared.
A lot of the guys came through Washington.
I remember I developed a lot of respect for progressive Jewish people because one card came.
Oh, after Schwerner, Goodman, and Chaney disappeared.
I walked into my office, assistant to Washington office.
And all these very, very, very nicely dressed, attractive, young, Middle-aged woman had taken over.
And they said, call so and so.
My husband gave him $500 first last campaign call.
He will answer us and call us once again.
And they call in congressman, which is my job, you know.
So I stand up at the corner of the office.
And nobody pays any attention to me.
And I said, this is my office and all these people learn to cover.
And his mother's from long island.
And they're all Jewish as a matter of fact.
And I said, damn, they're getting through to congresspeople at the end.
They were being able to speak to celebrate, to stand there and watch their work.
You know, and they call it.
And then one of the cars going down to Mississippi stopped to check in at the office.
And this big dark here, curly here, good looking kid came walking into the office and he looks in the back.
I said, mom, what are you doing here?
And she looked up and says, hey, what are you doing here?
I said, I'm going to go to Mississippi now and she ran out of the bank, kissed him.
And I said, damn, the car, my mother had been burning up the telephone lines from Jamaica.
She said, if you go to Mississippi, make you a get killed.
She didn't know what Mississippi was.
But somebody who had known some analogy of Jamaica, I'm a total artist.
She said, if you go to Mississippi, I'm going to get an FBI after you.
I said, you're going to get an FBI after me, aren't you, mom?
I said, but I'm not good.
That's okay. I got to work here in Washington.
So I was very struck by that mother who just kissed her son and said, you know,
grow a God, God bless you and send them off to Mississippi.
And seemed so proud of him, you know.
Was it hard enough to go to Mississippi?
Mm-hmm.
Well, my mother was straightening to get an FBI after me.
So, well, I finally got here where I didn't get it, where the right time I got to Mississippi,
they sent me back to Washington.
I go forget that.
What happened?
Fff.
Giot.
Make me as soon as I walked into the meet them.
And I said, no, I'm going to Mississippi.
I wanted to be a field organization.
I wanted to be a blue jeans and run from the sheriff into all the room and the kind of things.
And Kuntsela after Kinoa and Bill Kuntsela, they met me.
So, Mike, just a man we're looking for.
So, I turned over to the SNCC office to Jim Monsonis.
You going back to Washington?
I said, what for?
You going back to Washington to start the MFDP office?
I said, God, damn it.
We challenged into Mississippi Congressman.
You got to go back and start the office.
So, I had to turn around and go out to the way to Washington.
Did someone with that after the summer?
Yeah.
So, that had to be ended, so.
So, another guy headed south.
After the Jewish Marvand, her son met to move me.
And he started.
And who should burst in the office?
But Ralph Featherstone, with a big smile on his face and his chest all pulled to her.
I'd never seen him so happy and so exhalated and so energized.
I said, guess what, Mike?
I'm assistant director to Freedom Schools.
What was interesting about that is that in the short time of the orientation,
which is about a week at Mons, people out there work and had picked up the abilities of Ralph Featherstone.
And Ralph Featherstone was a great assistant director to Freedom School.
And he was the operative director because, what's in your list, guy?
Who was it?
Starting in the next.
I don't think was in Mississippi during the summer.
He had to have to write some other things and write the formulations of the committee.
But it was Ralph Featherstone who ran it.
And he was just as outpuffed up.
He was so proud.
And then a very good friend of mine, who Ralph Featherstone introduced me to.
Later on when I was running the MFDP office, Ralph Featherstone comes into the office with a really long,
red-haired white kid, a white young man.
I said, Mike, I don't brought you something.
I said, what's it say here?
He came to work in the office.
He was a volunteer in the Shobakronte.
And Ralph Featherstone was working in the Shobakronte after the disappearance of those people.
And that's when I met my best friend.
He's a very, very smart guy.
He was a philosopher, graduate student at Yale.
He was a graduate student at home.
She was a brightest student.
And he went to Mississippi and stayed over.
And he really loved Mississippi.
And he was a very perceptive guy.
His perception is a black culture and everything.
And he worked in the office for a while.
Very funny.
One time we had some victory in the challenge.
And we went out to celebrate.
And our office was done in southwest Washington, close to Capitol Hill.
So we went into this little restaurant, which was really a hillbilly kind of restaurant.
And we had dinner and we had a couple of drinks.
And then we had a couple more drinks.
And it was my friend, Lawrence Guyot, who, as you know, weighed 300 pounds.
Jan Goodman, who would be a great person for you to interview.
She was very, very smart when she has more political experience, certainly than I had.
She used to run it, working presidential campaigns.
And she was the assistant coordinator of the MFDP office for the challenge.
Jan Goodman, she's an all-night lawyer in New York, live in the village.
So, there was Alan, myself, Lawrence Guyot, and Jan Goodman.
There was four of us.
So we had dinner.
I had a drink, then I had another drink, and we were talking about things that were taken place.
And the whole administration, committee, and we were talking about, you know, Capitol Hill,
Godship, people inside the building, to a talk, or whatever, we were getting quite relaxed.
So I almost had two or three drinks, maybe three or four.
I don't know how many, it was four of us.
But when the bill came, it was $45.
There was a lot of money.
And I said, don't write guilty to be using that much of the movements money to have three or four drinks in this white restaurant.
But it's really working, God, it's going to be the restaurant.
And they said, oh my God, look at the bill.
How much money you got, I might have had $6 on me.
I didn't write it. I had four.
I finally got billed out.
But when we pulled our joint resources, the bill was like $45.
And we had about $25.
So I said, well, the only thing we can do is to place the 26 books we have on the table and run like hell for the door.
And Lawrence Guyot says, well, Mr. Chairman, I want to associate myself with those sentiments.
I'm a friend Alan, who rather than introduce us, I looked up and said, Mr. Chairman, as much as you might want to embrace those sentiments,
I doubt very much you're going to be able to implement them.
We all cracked up last.
And Lawrence Guyot said not to worry about it. And he reached into his pocket.
And he had been to a black church fundraiser. He had an annual of $2 bills in there.
So he paid off another $20 and put it down there.
Money is contributed to the MFDP for the challenge.
And I said, one of the time we have a ripped off any money from the movement.
That 20 books were settled a bill.
Well, Mr. Chairman, much as you went, one associate yourself with those sentiments, looking at his girth,
and said, that very much doubt that you're going to be able to implement them.
I was thinking about James Farmer about how he then had to be the fastest.
He just has to be able to outrun.
Yeah, probably would have been back in the back.
Absolutely.
And you talk about what it was like to work on the 1964 Atlantic City Democratic National Convention Challenge, your job in BC.
You'll work that summer.
Well, I left.
I mean, I made initial contacts, I think.
And I always worked in BC. I didn't travel.
A lot of the organizers had to do it right going to the state conventions, and getting committed from commitments from the Democratic delegation
that they would go a certain way.
But prior to that time, one had to make contact with the congressmen in Washington.
And through the congressmen or through all supporters in the state were learning about through the key local activists who were to go organized.
But that was organized in the congress.
And my main job, because once the summer project became known, a wave of propaganda swept through the beltway.
And it essentially was what the Mississippi crackers were saying.
And it's what the insipient right ring color weren't as well.
They don't know what we're saying.
That A is a totally quizzotic action that is doomed to failure.
And it is not doomed to failure.
It's totally, it is not a good faith action.
They pretend they're being us pretend to go on there to do education to run culture centers.
But they're really going down there to disrupt the state and to embarrass the state of the Mississippi and the national government, like freedom rights did.
So it's really a very cynical procedure on our part.
And number three, what these cynical activists, most adventurers trying to do is to get young white Americans down here to get them killed.
Which in sense they had out to me in the office, because I mean all these people, my colleagues, the people that met them were working with.
They were still American students.
And there are decent and well-meaning people.
And the last thing they wanted to do is kill anybody.
And why instead of talking about a terrorist who doing the killing, they're talking about the potential victims that we bring in it.
I mean, it was really perverse.
And people like Evans and Novak were right in that.
People like that guy was supposed to be the the Alsop brothers.
One of them was gay, it was the Alsop brothers.
Yeah, you know who I mean.
And they were naturally syndicated.
And even Drew Pearson got involved in a very curious way.
And there's another story that probably needs to be told.
But so all that propaganda started being pretent against the summer project.
How did you try to convert it?
Well, it's best for Kud.
Well, I didn't know, I mean, I could see what economists were right.
It was in me with that other guy that says Evans and Novak were kind of rather roses.
But this guy was austere and had gravitas.
This is me. the Alsop brothers.
And their names are all over history.
So I'd recommend them.
Could you spell it?
We did. I want to see him.
Jackie Kennedy (Jacqueline Bouvier Kennedy Onassis), to whom he was a great advisor and confidant.
That's a level that the Alsop brothers.
He came out and said, flat out that he had clear proof and evidence that what's Nick was trying to do was to create martyrs.
I was trying to lure people out here to get him killed to us, to embarrass the country.
So at the same time, this has been said,
there is a campaign of vilification taking place in Mississippi saying that the state is going to be invaded.
That these people are disease-ridden, syphilicted people coming to infect white women with various sexually transmitted diseases.
That they're coming. It's been financed by Fidel Castro and Cuba.
And the status pass in all the St. Cronin observed legislation in a special session.
It's illegal to rent a room to a visiting white person or a black person.
Look at this. They're buying tanks and tear gas dispenses and the blue paint, the pink of blue, so you know who's in demonstration.
They're sock-pile and shotguns and machine guns.
So a real crisis atmosphere has been created and the state.
And the Klan is burning crosses every weekend.
And then the media down there, the radio talk shows, and the print media, Jackson Clarion-Ledger, Jackson Daily News,
published all these very incited, what were you called it?
Incendiary, what no, incite.
Yeah, incite in comments.
And nothing else is appearing in a Mississippi media.
Demonizing the volunteers whom I'm up in Washington, recruiting, and I know it to be the best young Americans you can find, very earnest and well-meaning.
But creating an atmosphere where, if you're an ordinary young white, Mississippi and boy,
brought upon the rhetoric of the lost cause and the Confederate, whatever it is.
And Southern patriotism, then you would conclude very strongly that your patriotic duty as a young white person,
with the killies and traitors, were a comment to completely disrope the state,
besmirch, write womanhood, unspread communism, and disease.
I mean, if such a person were coming into my state, I'd want to ask them to, right?
So, and then we discovered that the same, a version of this was being circulated among liberals.
So, a young white woman at school in the middle, I sent us a letter that her father's best friend sent to him when he called on,
I said, my daughter is thinking of going to Mississippi to work on voter registration and education and working on freedoms.
We seemed like a good thing. What do you think?
And this guy wrote and said, that's the rhetoric of what they say. That's not what they intend.
They just want to get young white students killed.
And this person was very important in the Democratic Party, I can't remember who it was, what his exact title was.
But he was a mover and a shaker in Washington and I said, damn, if the establishment is saying this shit, we need to counter it.
And we'd call press conferences and we'd do whatever, nobody would show up or very few people would show up.
Every time we'd call a press conference, the white host, they would call a press conference, so they had a political press.
They were going to the MFD, the SNCC office, are you going to the white host?
And so, we were standing in that way.
And that is where I remember, so one of the things I started to do was to say, look,
it's a very less provocative, very dangerous, incendiary rhetoric and mobilization is taking place and trying to stay in the country, and paying no attention.
So we got to get some congressman, if you can get some decent congressman, maybe Adam Clayton, who's a committee chairman or somebody, he wouldn't do it.
I don't know if I got to talk to him, but to talk to congresspeople to see if there can be a congressman here.
And the circumstances in Mississippi, in which case, the media would have to attend.
And if they get the right witnesses, if they get black people to come and testify, if they get SNCC people to come and testify, there's no way the story can be suppressed.
So that was part of my job, we're probably referring to some of the project.
Is there a meeting with the other line, I'm sure, was that perhaps the...
I'm getting to that. I'm getting to that.
One of the... I remember speaking to people like congressman Ryan, I grew up in a liberal congressman from California, and...
Guy from Wisconsin, Castanmar, (Rep.) Robert Kastenmeier of Wisconsin.
The most interesting thing is that at Edita was standing up to this SNCC book, she married one of Castanmar's sons or something like that.
And I could say, I can tease him about your father in law.
But I was in his office, or should I say, in the age to?
I was in his actually younger, you know?
And I started to recont... Everything that was being said in the media, everything that the client was doing,
everything that Allen C. Thompson was doing, that the political leadership of the state was doing.
And what the media was saying, and I kept saying, you know, it seems closer, more and more to me, that if this continues, there's going to be killings, maybe even a bloodbath, there's going to be violence.
I mean, it's what is sitting... The programming for that.
And as I went on, just deducing evidence, and this happened, and this has been happening, and this has been happening.
I saw Castan Raya's head start moving down, and moving down, and moving down.
Like a burden was on his shoulders.
By the time I finished the description, his head was laying on the desk.
And I said, so Congressman, we've got to have a congressman here, and he says, we never get to hearing through, he said, the White House had posed to it, and the Democratic leadership had posed to it.
Were there posed because of upcoming challenge?
There was no challenge at this point, or you mean the challenge in Atlantic City?
I don't think anybody took that really real. It's just that, you know, business as usual, Congress took privilege, and they were pushed out in a position that is really agitators, common, and...
And also that, in a great many other Congressional committees, VIXACrats, because of their longevity, had seen their roles in there.
I mean, look, there was five Mrs. of congressman that were trying to unseat, and between the five of them, I think they had 235 years seniority, you know, or something like that.
But there's some unheard of figure, simply because after you won those little White primers, you get elected to office, and it's a lifetime job.
So they were able to jam things up in the Congress.
And that was why we said, okay, if we can get the Congressional hearing, we should try and get the own hearing.
And that letter you saw to Larry in hands, very, how we could go get it and read from it if you wanted to know record, was all we did.
And what we did was we got Bob and the people in Mississippi movement to get the bunch of local people, Black people, I don't think, for having a white witnesses.
And we rented the National Theatre in Washington. We contacted a lot of prominent American citizens. I remember Norman Mailer, I called him up to come.
And he was a very good guy. I had a Brooklyn accent. He said, geez, you know, I love to do that. I really want to do it. But maybe it's not me a best interest.
You know, my reputation ain't really so good these days. He had just stabbed his wife. He said, so my presence there might not serve your purposes. And I say, thank you, Mr. Miller.
And I respected him for that. So what we did was, I mean, I remember we got these people from Mississippi to testify in this hearing.
Of course, being prominent among them. Hartman Turnbow, being prominent among them. Mr. Miles, E.W. Steptoe. It's a steptoe, a great story.
You know what I mean? You know, E.W. Steptoe is little, about five foot four or something, and very slightly bit.
And Amite County was a huge, big redneck. And this is how to take care of her, but Lee.
For leading voter registration in Emmett County, E.W. Steptoe takes down a second group of people, black people to go and register to vote.
And E.W. Steptoe against that almost petite guy. But brave as a lion, as a group of maroons, marines, is brought into the quarters.
And the sheriff comes looming over him and puts his hand on his gun and said, Steptoe, state your business. What are you doing here?
You remember E.W. Steptoe's answer? E.W. Steptoe says, where sheriff, if I live, I'm already registered to vote.
And at that point, the answer to that question wasn't clear, whether E.W. Steptoe would live, right?
So we brought him up to testify. And Moodikim, she brought two young men, two beautiful young guys, both fourteen and twelve years old, who testified about being put in this stock kid.
There were some of the best witnesses. I mean, we got these distinguished Americans, it was in the National Theater.
Even higher stenographers to the right to don't know, we made a tape record, and one of the other.
But the transcript was developed just like a congressional hearing. And it was published just like a congressional hearing.
The transcript of those hearings is something I wish I would see a copy of. But that's the kind of stuff we used to do.
That's the kind of stuff we used to do in preparation for the summer project.
You said earlier that there was a memo that you wrote like to have a copy of.
That's the Voting Rights Act.
Okay. Well, well, fine, after let me ask you. So, what, I stung away over my question.
Miss Baker worked on the 1964 Atlantic City Democratic National Convention Challenge out of Washington.
Miss Baker came up. But then I did that in the start work.
But when this summer begun, I left the office and Jim on so in the stakeholder.
And Miss Baker came up and started doing, and after traveling together to the various state conventions and stuff like that, I'm carrying a message in that.
Had I maintained in the office, had I remained in the office that I probably had done some of that.
But, you know, there's also the question of my very clear and evident, Jimmy, a con accent.
I'm not an American citizen. So, it seemed like it wasn't smart.
It's a single animal's effect. It's important to run it around in your own two years.
I mean, I was just a student at Conventions, they didn't get a challenge.
The Mississippi delegation, who, I mean, who did it as far as my good friends and missus here,
who did fun talk and make farewell to be doing that?
So, what were you doing instead?
None of your damn business.
There was a lady.
I was washing some clothes in a laundromat in New York.
And this woman, the very distinctive, good looking woman, a very distinctive Russian accent, which I want to attempt to imitate, asked me if I could help her with fuller clothes.
And I did.
And I had a conversation and she gave me her telephone number.
And I called up the number.
And the woman who answered had a French accent.
And I said, you came to the person I'm trying to call because the lady I'm calling has a distinctly Russian accent.
And I'm looking for her.
And she says, well, it's zero message. And I give her the message.
She says, she will call you back.
But then the woman who called me back had a German accent.
And she said, what is going on here?
When it turns out she was a character actress.
And she had all these accents, no, but she had been going like, so I spent a couple of months when I exiled myself from this Macoffe's.
I had a picture I don't use to want to be promotion pictures with this lady of the many accents.
Were you around during the actual 1964 Atlantic City Democratic National Convention Challenge or were you exiled?
I wasn't in Atlantic City.
But I got all the reports from people who were asleep people and came back.
And I really was very tempted to go to Atlantic City.
A curious sense of appropriateness and protocol.
I said, look, I'm not working in this Macoffe's anymore.
I'm not actually on this next staff.
So actually, I want to go push myself for the Atlantic City and present myself.
But in fact, the movements, the tone and the sneakiness didn't have to be on staff.
Well, the kinds of people who are showing up, if I'd gone, I mean, all my friends from Niagara, they're welcome to me.
And I said, where I go up and make demands on sneak resources, needing a place to stay in.
I'm sad to not be in a minute, because I was not on the sneak peak or anything more.
So I was very broke. So that's why I wasn't here.
And then you started working on the congressional challenge?
Well, then I came back after someone was over after the convention challenge was over.
And they said, look here, they said, what up?
There had been some offers of some literary people who wanted to sponsor me for a kind of literary patronage.
That's really what the fuck it was.
I want to couple of national prizes for short story, right? And stuff like that.
And one day I went to Donald Mattoid and there was this very New York sophisticated advice in the corner of woman car.
This to tell me, well, yes, ma'am.
I just went on another story, magazine publication on this story magazine.
She says, I just read your short story. It was brilliant. And I would so like to handle you.
I said, you like to handle me, ma'am. She says, I mean, your work. I mean your work.
So I quite an agent who had been Richard Wright's agent and who gave me a very interesting letter that William Faulkner had written to Richard Wright.
Very paternalistic. You want to hear about it?
What he essentially said was, as soon as I read it between the lines, Faulkner was the acknowledged master of represented Mississippi reality in literature and represented from a white perspective.
Now, the income Richard Wright who was vaguely on the left might have been a communist and is writing the same experience from a black perspective and the two things don't mesh.
So Faulkner, it was very much my son. I read your book and it was very much a new rhetoric of the new criticism, the kind of defecation of art and the artist.
I have read your work and you appear to have talent and I believe one day you could be an artist.
And you might succeed. You just might succeed in the difficult task of becoming an artist if you were less too hatred and so on and so on.
So in other words, to regard that message, don't know, might accept you at a high table of literary art.
To be gone in that view. But if you only can get away from hatred and recrimination, one day you may become an artist.
And she gave me a copy of that letter which I never kept. I didn't keep my account letters for, you know.
But anyway.
Yeah, so I'd gone to a meeting and at the meeting was the editor of the Southern Review, whose name I cannot recall right now.
I write to for the New Yorker magazine and this agent. And this was a meeting in New York.
In fact, the guy I was staying with was the editor of Crown Pressward published by last story from this contest.
And that's a story in which it's got a community of victims. And he has to do with a young black man at a bus stop, a white woman at the bus stop.
And a drunk black man who comes up and starts to aggressively approach the white lady and then the young black guy intercedes.
He's trying to see a face for the white black, for the drunk, the black drunk. He's trying to see even from getting into trouble with the police,
what he don't want to appear to be kissing up to the white lady. So he's got a problem, hooked on handling it.
And at one point when they sit down on the bus, the woman touches him on his knee and says, thank you to get his attention.
Says, thank you. And I remember the editor of the Southern Review said, that's a very intimate gesture. Very intimate gesture. Get it old, right?
But anyway, I might as meet him and they proceeded to have me hold talent today.
And I think I really have a career as a writer. And there was some talk, really was a strategy.
I would write two or three short stories, which I would submit to the editor of the Southern Review. I know which I guess would point negotiation if it's a right point. They would publish there.
Which would be the basis for seeking a contract for me for a novel. And then somebody had a friend who had an apartment and Venice are naples, who I didn't speak the language, so I'd have to write.
That was vacant and could be made accessible to me, available to me. And I could do this novel right quick.
I just point out that I've been out to Jamaica for four years. I wasn't African American Bay in a stretch of the imagination.
But I'm not saying anything, you know, I mean, this right and now we are a talent, right to go right to know.
And so obviously what I had was patrons, literary patrons, you know, kind of patronage and clientilism that go into Harlem Renaissance and the black literary experience.
And so you can very discover, you know, it is three white people taking an interest in my career telling me how talented I was.
And at the end of which, blues from Blues for Mister Charlie, Walgreens, played, had been on Broadway and created a great leader controversy.
And the agent said to me, said, oh, by the way, said to a group. I mean, we're at the initial discussion. And I said, okay, we're about to write very good.
I could write these stories, we get the country out, everything is in place for a literary career, right?
Did you understand something? By the way, have you seen blues from Blues for Mister Charlie?
I don't know a couple of people said they had, or maybe they said they had, and she says, well, just atrocious, just awful.
That James Baldwin is finished. I had a great leader respect for James Baldwin. That James Baldwin is finished.
In fact, I think we're ready to stand for a new black writer.
I said, oh, is that what's great about it? So I left and went back to Washington and called it Jim Foreign.
And said, I'm coming back to Snickers, I've come down south. So that does what happened.
We're discussing what the black writers responsibility were on a vote. Some of the vote raising in Washington.
I remember we had to send out and get liquor from bootlegs because the stores were in open.
And Jim got to swing over it and says, well, my young brothers and sisters, here we are.
I, James Baldwin, a black writer, must in some way represent you.
No, you didn't elect me, and I didn't ask for it, but there we are.
But I can promise you this, if you can promise me that you will never, ever accept any of the degraded and reductive definitions of yourself and your humanity,
that this republic has prepared for you, I, James Baldwin can promise you that I should never betray you.
That was the high point of that evening. I've never forgotten it. Stoke the Quartz at his book.
None of us were there for God and Jim never did.
So when his woman says, you know, that's probably not done to you. That Jim's program has finished already for a new black writer.
I used to stand to get my asshole to there. You know, I'm not going back.
I think it was when the comic book came out.
Or it could have been when the Harder They Come".
But they got their full drive, probably said, Madison, Michael Steadman, I thought that was your agent.
I hadn't spoken to the woman for 20 years, you know.
But she, she wanted a claim.
Like she wanted to reestablish the professional relationship, I guess.
So did you work in the South for a while or did you immediately get sent back to?
On the next plane.
I get to the meeting.
It may have been the meeting.
Could have been at Weveland.
Or could have been at one seminary in Atlanta. You can check which one it was after the conventional challenge.
After the convention challenge at Weveland, the convention challenge at Weveland, the
convention challenge at Weveland, the convention challenge at Weveland, the convention challenge.
Yeah, again, okay. So it was a theological seminary in Atlanta.
That's where it was.
And as soon as I walked and now merely had done to flirt with two or three of the volunteers,
and Giaz and Kuntzlanke and I came here and don't know me, I could have been looking for you.
We've been looking for you. We need you. I said, what's wrong?
You got to go back to Washington.
That's when officer didn't speak freedom democratic party.
They had me $200 a stat. The officer sent me back to Washington.
Yeah, I'm going to have you in Mississippi with me.
And they went back to Washington for the challenge.
So Giaz and admit 200 books and cash, they go rent an office and equip it and get ready to call her a challenge.
No, it's important to understand the challenge strategy.
The convention or the practice of challenge and seats in Congress really begun with reconstruction.
We are a lot of Southern delegations were coming up and Republicans were challenging.
I'm already Republican, Republican Democrats would challenge them.
I swear they truly represented the state or they truly had one legitimate access to the seats that were going.
And to do that, a process was developed.
First of all, that Congress is the only judge, obviously, only legitimacy.
So you couldn't challenge for a seat in court.
You couldn't go to a federal court and fail a law, a suit and say, and the true representative.
It's all predicated on the vote in Congress.
Which means that ultimately it's a political decision and it's all predicated on who has majority in the Congress.
And if you're a minority party, if you're a party don't control a majority and there is no point you're going to challenge them for the seat because they're going to vote you.
And the Democrats had a huge majority.
But the process that I mean in 1964 when we were doing it, 6 to 5, the Democrats had a huge majority. That's number one.
Number two, Congress is the only judge.
And the next element is the only person who can challenge a seat of any elected member and a member claiming to be elected is somebody who also ran in the election and is challenging for the seat.
So you have to have been a candidate.
And then if such a candidate comes forward, the only way you can challenge the seat is when the Congress convenes.
And the speaker says, all rise to be sworn in.
And as the Congress is rising, then you have to have another Congress person who represents your interest.
Raise for instance, Mr. Chairman, get the attention of the chair.
And the chair says, right as a gentleman, raise.
Raise the challenge to seat and a representative, Khodsby of Miss Khodsby of Mississippi for external reasons.
And once that protocol takes place, then the challenge goes into effect.
And then what next follows from that, if you get the attention of the chair and you challenge the seat and the chair then says to the challenge congressman, please step aside.
Why does he say that?
Can't take the seat until it's investigated.
Or not to disinvestigate it.
He can take the seat at the will of Congress.
But there's no Congress until this world end.
The kid, do shit.
So you step aside, and then the body could turn around and he's the representative.
And you sit back, don't.
Five minutes is all the time it took.
Or the body might vote. He's in the representative.
Or there's a real challenge here, in which case a process is input into motion.
The challenger gets his document and his evidence and is sent to the host committee on internal affairs.
The guy claim in the seat who has been certified presumably by the party in control in that state.
He sends us credentials and his evidence and the host committee stretches it out and votes on it.
There could either vote that a challenge has no validity.
In which case the congressman who was sent forward with the credentials will be seated.
And I can happen in a week or two and days.
It happens very shortly.
Or they can vote at the Congress that a challenge has validity.
And presumably they could vote that the challenger is entitled to the seat.
But that's just the committee.
So when the committee makes that determination, they send it to the complete host who settled the issue.
The only way a seat in the host can be challenged.
There is another stipulation or another process which is involved.
And that is if the host doesn't seat the challenge party and says that the challenge should be sent to the host committee.
To be adjudicated.
The challenger can go into the constituency and seek depositions from every election official, from every elected official, from local people.
And those depositions, his right to seek those depositions has a power of subpoena.
So these people have to come, have to answer the questions, have to take testimony.
And that testimony could be then sent to the host.
But that whole process is not triggered unless the host so votes after the challenge congress people have stood down.
You follow that?
So what do you need to challenge the seat?
What do you need?
No, no, prior to that what you need.
People claim.
So what has got to claim the seat?
You can challenge the abstract and you have to have challenges who had run to claim the seat.
Now in Mississippi at that time there was no way any black person could get under ballot.
Because you'd have to go through the primary.
Or you'd have to go through the nomination process and be accepted by the state to put you on the official ballot.
So that was all to the question.
Unless you won the Democratic primary or you won a Republican primary about paternesty.
And both of the sponsors were at a time really right.
So the only way we could get challenges was to run people in a freedom election.
But a freedom election has no official status.
So what would cause the host representatives are anybody else to accept it as being a legitimate challenger.
So you can see it's a very uphill struggle.
But after the convention challenge in Atlantic City, which ended with incredibly good, well, badwill and recriminations and snake being abused.
As trying to talk Peter, the election of Lyndon Baines Johnson trying to destroy the Democratic Party,
being able to understand in politics, being politically naive or politically sinister, whichever one you prefer.
And we were absolutely persona non-grash and the careers of belt-repolitics and internal politics at the state.
And that's a situation in which Lawrence Guyot is sending back into Washington to go challenge these seasons.
But Lawrence Guyot, bless his heart, also had a sense of arrogance and subversiveness.
Because after we left Atlantic City, being abused by every facet of the Democratic Party possible.
And even by some of all allies, we were abused by Robert Spaker, the National Consulate Churches,
which he thought at all, political acumen, left a lot to be desired, or that were dependable people to work with politically.
He wasn't sure. He came back over after we can recall in Washington.
Are he invited us to meet number one and he was surprised that we went?
But to go back to Washington, representing the MFDP, is like to go to Tel Aviv, R.J. Russelam, say, representing the Nazi party.
I mean, it wasn't a proper thing to do.
But right after the convention, when all this recrimination has been heaped on all ahead, Lawrence Guyot went down to Mississippi or recruited Mrs. Hamer, Mrs. (Victoria) Gray, Mrs. Annie Devine to run in the second district, the third district, and I believe the fifth.
And printed up all these posters and he declared, you said we were in Cetan, Atlantic City, but we have undained loyalty to the Democratic Party.
We have undying loyalty to the ticket. And we are going to campaign and support the ticket, which gives us a lot of fun.
Because what's going to happen now is that the whole Democratic Party, the whole Dixiecrats in Mississippi, is going to support Barry Goldwater and support the Conservatives.
And maybe the Labour Union, the only FLCI, or unless you liberal, is that supporting the Democrats.
But the only people who are supporting the Democrats, forthrightly, is MFDP.
Most of whom can't vote.
Most of whom can't vote, that's the other thing.
And second of all, to all rights that support the Democratic National Ticket, is a kiss of death and Mississippi.
So I never forget we had these posters printed up.
Lyndon Baines Johnson not the top of the ticket.
He worked on the NETIM and then the NETIM was in the second district. Mrs. Hamer, MFDP candidates, is what we call them.
I remember writing a letter to the Democratic National Committee, like Campea and saying, you know,
we understand that the President and the Vice President are very busy campaigning all over the country.
But we, the only group at Element of the Democratic Party, is supporting the National Ticket and the State.
There are so-and-a-campaign materials, said in these posters.
And even if the President himself can't come, we would have very encouraged, you know, effort to support the National Ticket.
If Mrs. Johnson would come, I would sponsor her in the talk.
Right? For some reason we didn't get no answer.
Yeah, we all rush.
Sad, sad, sad.
But anyway, so we ran these freedom election campaigns, took a freedom vote.
It's not part of the official vote.
I named it the ticket, led by Lyndon Baines Johnson and Hubert H. Humphrey.
And I will vote, Lyndon Baines Johnson and Hubert H. Humphrey carried the state, comfortably, as did Mrs. H. Hamam, Mrs. (Victoria) Gray,
was the Vice-Devine Dewey seats.
And it's not the basis of this, that we're going to go challenge the election.
Now, Joseph Rauh, who is UAW general counsel and ADA chair,
also was Court Chairman of what that coalition calls.
Remember to read a story, or when said, Joseph Rauh said we can be seated, and he might write a brief, the whole meeting turn?
So he felt, not to the old reason, was quite wrongly, that the only reason we had even got in the door at Atlantic City,
was because of his agency and patronage.
Actually, we got in the door because of Goodman, Schwerner, Chaney, because we took all those things to the National State Conventions,
and all these Northern states that had young volunteers in Mississippi and the summer project,
who all we contacted them and they rushed to the state conventions to talk about what their experiences were.
So the murderers were in a Goodman, Shunian, and it gave us a great deal of currency people understood it.
So, even without Joseph Rauh's considerable influence, and his happen written the brief,
we would have still had some momentum and currency to get into the convention,
we would have had support in the delegations, right? Michigan, California, New York, places like that.
And I will recapitulate you the whole story of the various votes on the credentials committee,
and how people's votes returned their own. You know that.
But they felt that we were a ungrateful, apolitical, didn't understand patronage and responsibility, or irresponsible.
Joseph Rauh felt that very strong. I remember when I got back to Washington,
I was in the office, or when I was in the FDP office, right?
I got this bill for maybe a thousand dollars, which was a lot of money for the printing of the briefs.
So I called up Joe who's a poll for where I collected liberal and said, Mr. Rao,
I have here a bill for your brief which was presented in Atlantic City,
and the MFDP never ordered any print and I didn't order any print and you must have ordered it,
so can I send you the bill? So no, you're independent. It's your brief. You prefer it.
And you know what the phone is. God damn it.
And before we are, I said that was, that was my first conversation with Joseph Rauh.
My first conversation with Joseph Rauh should have talked about what Ben 3 Prodigyx was all about.
When I was in the Smith office,
Bill Gregory, you know, it wasn't Gregory. It was the other guy, Dr.
Dr. Pooh.
Other black comedian was also an I Spy, was an FBI agent, his career started.
Bill Cosby? Bill Cosby.
Right. Bill Cosby.
Had agreed to do a benefit for us.
Some lady knew him, very attractive lady, so she said, I said, no, I'm in the biblical sense of the word.
We said, there's this great, there's this great young black comic.
And he's got a TV series on ABC coming up and he's very funny.
I think I can get him to do a benefit figure, so that had Cosby doing the benefit.
I got cramped an auditorium at Howard and Student Nonviolent Coordinating Committee was very broke and we sold all the tickets.
So there's about $5,000 coming in from it and we needed it very badly.
And some guy calls me up from some branch of the district,
the District of Columbia government, maybe the agents that these were charitable contributions,
and says that we're not registered as a charitable organization.
We have no business having the concert and if we go ahead and have the concert,
I'll be in violation of the law and he's going to go on imprison me.
And he said, god damn it, Student Nonviolent Coordinating Committee needs this money.
The concert is going to be three days.
We have cramped an auditorium and it's my name is saying if we have the concert, I'm going to jail.
What hell am I going to do?
And then somebody says, call up Joseph Rauh.
So who the hell is Joseph Rauh?
This was earlier, you know, when I was at Student Nonviolent Coordinating Committee, not the MFDP.
I said, always the most powerful liberal in the district, you'll be able to help you.
There's that person who told me that was a plant.
But he gave me the number.
So I called it, I said, Mr. Ro, my name is Mike Thelwell, I'm a co-ordinator at the Student Nonviolent Coordinating Committee Washington office.
Oh, hello Mike, what can I do for you?
I said, well, so you know, the organization is strapped, it's broke.
We have a concert coming up with benefit by Bill Cosby,
with solo toilet tickets.
One call from somebody in the district of Columbia's government saying that if we have the concert,
I'm going to jail, I've been violation of the law.
And I should have paid close attention to what Joseph Rauh said to me.
I said, well, Mike, I never saw a situation yet that couldn't be fixed.
Let me get on it.
And that's the last I heard of Maggoyne to jail.
We had a concert, it got them money, and that's the last I heard of it.
Now what I suspect was that it was all a fraud.
That whoever called me up pretending to be,
our perpetrator to be from the district government was Joseph Rauh's man.
Whoever told me and gave me the number to call him was Joseph Rauh's man.
And what he wanted was patronage, he wanted me to be grateful to him.
Well, America, there was a situation that couldn't be fixed, I took care of it.
And it disappeared, right?
Well, that's his attitude.
There's no situation that came to be fixed.
I didn't understand that at the time.
It's much later, it's a person that's what had happened.
All right.
So now I'm going back to Washington.
And if people aren't actually spitting on me,
but they're really not talking to me.
And I have to go to Leadership Conference on Civil Rights.
Now what?
To represent MFDP.
And I guess monsooness of whoever it is is going to represent SNCC.
Offer some reason as represent in both organizations at Leadership Conference on Civil Rights,
the leadership conference at Leadership Conference on Civil Rights.
Now what that is,
is an organization of the national representatives,
we lobbyists.
The chairman is always Clarence Mitchell Jr.
The general executive secretary is always Joseph Rauh.
The red here, the leader who represents the UAW, she's always there.
She's the UAW lobbyist.
She's the one who brought John Conyers around to introduce him when he got elected that year.
NCC Commission on Religion and Race.
The area lobbyist is there.
Methodist organization of religion and race,
they're lobbyists this year.
I know host of other organizations, I've been 90 of them.
All of them come to the meeting,
what about 30 of them fall out the game to the meeting every week.
And so did I.
Because I got to go to represent the interests of SNCC and the MFDP.
About the only person who would say hello, greet me and smile
was Episcopal Bishop of Washington, DC.
Tall guy, very dignified waspegai,
who looked like central casting and version of what the bishop should look like.
Who was that?
Paul Moore Jr.
He was always very decenter.
And after I had bought Spake,
who had felt kind of betrayed the other parties of investment in the summer project,
he started.
He asked so meeting, what did.
And people in the office saying, you know,
that's the establishment group of people we shouldn't go to,
I said, nobody would invite us to meet, we got to go.
And me and Jan,
Jan Goodman went to the meeting, represented MFDP.
I'm a walk in the little game face on looking for more abuse.
And Robert Spike said, glad you came.
Thank you very much for coming.
I've been doing a considerable lot of thinking about Atlantic City.
And I believe I'm at Iran.
I believe I must say I might have had some impressions which aren't quite accurate.
And we talked about, and then he became an ally again.
And we, you know, reached, that is the first breakthrough we made.
Actually, in terms of sequence,
knowing I was the first.
No, we have a known set, remember, on this challenge.
And that our challenges, the people, the contestants for this seat on this
is the famous Greenlanders Define.
What the NAACP, you aid W, all leadership conference,
well, all activists, the democratic activists, the labor guys, you aid W,
and NAACP's, most of all, and Joe Rahue felt illused.
And I think, by the way, he was trying to be a very honest broker in Atlantic City.
He has got nobody right from all of a sudden.
But they were vindictive.
And what they're saying to the leadership conference,
and when they make their own on Congress, because they're lobbyists,
and what the democratic leadership point to hear is that,
they so-called congressional challenges, total fraudulent,
our contestants, or not contestants, in an illegitimate election,
to which we agreed that it couldn't be because there were, by racism,
that the vote has no meaning, that the Mississippi delegation is solid and illegitimate,
and all of what should be dismissed.
The delivery had arguments to counter.
And we kept saying, and they said, there is no way the Congress,
the key point, is going to seat these three people on the basis of no freedom election.
To which we have to argue, that's absolutely correct.
And we're not claiming this, we're not asking for the seat in our vote candidates.
And what you're asking for, we're asking for you to advocate the seats,
not seat away from the recipients, because it's mountain of evidence
that black people, 40% of the state have been disfranchised.
So, on the day Congress opens a wants you not to seat them,
or wants you to open the challenge,
we don't think that the Congress is finally going to conclude that Ms. Grimmis,
the vice-demon, wants to be seated, but they would conclude in our rationality,
all fairness, that the elections are fraudulent,
rather than disfranchisement to half the population,
and that they will call for new elections in Mississippi on the federal auspices.
That was our strategy.
It was very complicated to think to sell on the floor their hopes are representative
and stuff like that, especially if you don't get a chance to sell it.
Now, if you think about the process I described to you,
the only way we're going to get a chance to sell it is if the speaker recognizes
a congressman who will get up and challenge the seat in other Mississippians.
And the conventional wisdom in the leadership conference in Surrey,
that wouldn't find a single congressman to do it.
Can't nobody is going to even be the last for coming out for real.
This bullshit, student fantasies, so we're going to find a congressman.
So it took us a long time to find a congressman.
You remember who that was?
The congressman really emphrates Ryan of New York.
He represented the Blue Stock and District Arteratives of the very liberal district.
He was a convinced Catholic man himself.
And he was a Maverick.
He never voted around with a host leadership.
And remember the guy Alan Arterne Eurbo, who feather introduced us to.
And the reason I tell you about Alan, he told incredible stories about feather initial or quality.
It was me and Alan going to go talk to congressman Ryan,
I figured two kintos and said, you know, there's a congressman who will
understand different challenges.
I was going and when the elevator stopped working, I was climbing stairs.
I was climbing and climbing towards the top of the host office building.
And she said, look at me, I said, God damn, they haven't worked here with the pigeons.
You know, he obviously don't have no status because I mean,
couldn't even call it an office.
This is a crib he had in the ceiling of the office building.
I mean, he had absolutely no credit or credibility with the host leadership.
Just from the jar, if you have his absolute intent to talk to him.
And he said, you're very happy to introduce this bill here, the happy challenge.
And I went leaving Alan and said to me, you know, something bowed to him.
I said, yeah, he's a very short guy.
He said, you know, the host leader, the speaker of the host was from South Boston.
The congressman was this?
No, no, no, before to put me in.
And I had that name at the tip of my tongue too.
What we learned that was congressman Ranozaman of small stature sir.
And for that whole challenge to work, it was essential that the congressman
was able to raise into challenges he can be recognized.
And we knew very well that the speaker of the host, Honorable John McCormick of South Boston,
an average wide politician of the old school,
was perfectly capable of not seeing Will Chamberlain if he rose from the floor.
And he didn't want to see him.
So we knew he couldn't see Congress, but really, it fits right, right?
Well, you know, that old rascal John McCormick was very funny.
James Roosevelt II, was a congressman.
And he told us a story one time, covered discussing the problems around him with John McCormick.
He said, oh, John is a fan of fellow.
Turns out the congressman had a speaking engagement in New York, didn't tell anybody left Washington, went to New York.
A vote was coming up.
And John McCormick needed his vote.
He said, there's a vote, technically, somebody handed him a phone.
And he heard this average bro coming at him over the phone.
Oh, Jimmy, Jimmy, Jimmy, by what would you pour, sainted mother's say,
if she was to know you had abandoned John McCormick in his own need?
Oh, Jimmy, Jimmy, my boy, curse the day.
What would you pour, sainted mother's say, congressman Roosevelt said,
he caught an extra to back to Washington and cast his vote.
Okay, so we knew we had to do something.
We had to get some congressman to support William Fitts Ryan.
All the time, Mitch Allen, Robert, and everybody, we don't have a single congressman.
I remember the day in the leadership conference when they were saying,
an Australian to talk up the challenge.
He said, do you even have a congressman to challenge?
He said, yes, we do.
And their jobs drop.
And he said, who, who, who?
I said, William Fitts Ryan.
I said, oh, and they laughed, right?
So, what we decided to do, we didn't know how to even get the challenge recognized.
And the administration was saying, and the Mississippi delegation was saying,
it was a totally fascist challenge, without merit it wouldn't be recognized.
I wouldn't go anywhere.
And the public in Mississippi was believing that.
But remember now that Lyndon Baines Johnson had very broad coot deals.
And he had brought in 46 freshman congressmen when they're the landslide against good water.
And his e-bomb monger himself.
He said, very cynical advertisement of the Washington cloud, right?
So, there was 47 or so freshman congressmen who were indebted to Lyndon Baines Johnson.
But the thing is, they had to be oriented, look, I didn't know how Washington works.
So, we got a program for the orientation of these freshman Democrats.
And we saw that there were having an orientation meeting at four o'clock,
one evening in some hotel downtown.
I forget which hotel it was.
So, he's clear to give them money and rented a little room next door for six o'clock,
for six o'clock that evening.
And myself and John and some other volunteers stood outside the door as these freshmen were going in
and handed them this very well developed invitation.
You're invited by MFDP to attend an orientation meeting next door at six o'clock.
Over the four to seven of them, about 15 came.
I remember who there were. One was John Connys, Democratic Michigan.
One was Patsy Mink.
And the other one whose name I don't remember was the best of them all.
A tall satin-in pay fellow in a black suit.
Who has eternal taste?
One's in fact a local on the take-off from upstate New York.
So, these guys came in and it's thanked them for coming.
And said we're lucky to hear what we invited you here.
And we told them the whole old version of the challenge.
The new about trying to good men and cheney.
And we were asking them to simply to raise with Congressman Ryan when Congress convened.
And there's this long silence.
Then the tall satin-in very pale waspigay from upstate New York said,
Ah, shucks. He said, the seat I'm in has been occupied by a Republican for the last 80 years.
I'm the first Democrat who ever got elected to that seat in 80 years, maybe just 50 years.
And I figured I got two years to be Washington before I'd be elected again.
So I'm going to as well do something good while I'm here. You got me.
I said, thank you, Captain.
And then, Pat, some minks says, I don't see how I could do otherwise.
I said, thank you, Congressman Minks.
John Conyers came to me and said, you know, I just came back.
And he was brought to that meeting by that same red here at Liddy who was a lobbyist for the UAW,
who was introducing him around the place.
He said, listen, and he was really distressed.
He said, I just came a very handsome young guy he was too.
I just came back from meet with a speaker.
And he assures me he's going to put me in the House Judiciary Committee.
And the House Judiciary Committee never had a black person.
It was very, it was important committee in Congress.
He said, so I don't know if I can really support you.
And I said, but I'm a taste of that.
That's between you and your conscience, but take it the truth to have a black person
on the House Judiciary Committee is very important.
So if you can't support yourself, I understand.
And he was very grateful to hear me say that.
20 years later when I went back to Washington, 30 years later.
When I went back to Washington working on the South African apartheid issue,
I went to his office with my ears and hit it at a black caucus.
And I said, Mr. Kanye, I'm like, he said, I know you.
I know you're a man of color.
And you remember the first game to Washington 30 years earlier, you know?
And so we got minks, we got this, we're tall on the tika.
Oh, we got three or four more.
So I went back to leadership conference and then we're going to start steering so well.
We have five congressmen, was it the agree that the rights with congressmen are I and some Michelin, Rose, I, Rose, go, but who are they?
I said, you know, I just don't have a list of me today.
I really don't have that information.
I was going to make the same mistake we made in Atlantic City.
And then some support to send us a letter and I cannot remember who the congressman was because in all all lobbying, we only went to liberals.
And as far as we were concerned, we were liberal, we knew we're Democrats.
So we assumed we had the votes of the five black Democrats, you know, congressman, Nick's William L. Dawson, Adam Clayton Powell Jr.
And Augustus F. Hawkins and one other, we figured we had those five black votes there would stand.
Even some of them was very uncertain if they wanted to do it because the leadership was saying no.
But somebody sent us a letter from a Thomas B. Curtis through it was.
And he wrote them back saying they should let the leadership conference leadership was saying there is no issue here.
There is no contestants to get.
There's no real claim into the seat.
There were not an any legitimate election.
There's no way the host could see them.
So please forget it.
And the so also porter who his constituent who got this letter sent it to us very distressed.
I said to them look real right in my letter.
So I wrote them a long letter explaining that we didn't expect him and Gray and Divine to be seated.
But a historic injustice to the black voter in the state of Mr. Benad forgotten the role of the Republican party after reconstructing.
That was in part to me.
But as I was telling them, got at us somebody had asked Bill Higgs.
I went out to Mississippi, I guess because he was gay and he was working in Congress and he used to work with us.
And he said, oh, this congressman Curtis.
Congressman Curtis on the zero.
Why is it my idea?
He's a very, very important Republican.
He's very powerful Republican.
So our Rotomulus long letter explaining that we had a legitimate challenge that we really wanted to challenge the seat of these Congress people.
And that we didn't expect to be seated.
But we hoped that the seats would be clear and vacant and a new election on the federal auspices.
A fair election would take place.
And I got like a card here with non-committer letter from Curtis saying,
we thank you for the explanation.
It clarifies a great deal.
We will take it on a consideration.
So I'm like that, right?
On the day, there we had another meeting.
We had a meeting, an earlier meeting, to support us around the country to generate support in Congress for the vote.
And there are two guys in the meeting who had to be SBI agents except if I would do better than that.
And there were really ill-fitting suits.
And in such a meeting, you know, it's all kinds of progressives, sort of kind of counter-culture,
or their intellectuals, college professors, they look too edy.
These were some working class looking guys with very uncomfortable.
And the discussion went on with all the flowing rhetoric and the high-partist seats and the other academic kind of bullshit.
And these guys were looking more and more uncomfortable.
And they came up to me and said, we're from the Union of Electricians.
And what was the name of that guy who everybody claimed was a communist?
That was a leader?
Forget his name.
So I'm so sent us.
He said, you learn a good job, kid.
And you have a discussion.
And then he said, what's happening?
I said, well, the leadership won't give us any space.
They won't give us any questions.
Things that really operate.
Anyway, Maslow's name was Will Maslow or something like that?
I forget.
Anyway, he said, anyway, we'll set to give this.
And he handed me a check for $100,000 in an envelope.
And he said, now tell me something.
Congressman Sonser of Philadelphia, of Pennsylvania.
What's he doing?
I said, have you been calling this? I've said, we didn't want to talk to me.
He said, don't worry about it.
Kid, you got him.
We got to go.
And they left.
So no rhetoric, no theorizing, no nothing.
Give me the $1,000.
March, go to the air.
When I got to my office, that Monday,
cutting me towards over a weekend.
I got to the office, join Gavin's system.
And Mike, my Congressman Green,
of the Ohio State of Pennsylvania,
has been calling. He's called four times a small and a red.
He really wants to talk to you.
I said, damn.
You guys, I said, one class, conscious workers,
worth a thousand students.
So they delivered that vote.
All right.
So it come time now for the vote to take place in Congress.
And then we, as far as we know,
we have about eight or nine people supposed to rise with Congress when we're on.
So if you're good, even if John W. McCormack is having a very near-sighted day,
he can't fail to see nine people rise and operate.
And I don't know that Curtis has done anything.
But then there was another inspiration we had.
Lawrence Guyot and the F.D. Piedsen,
a lot of people to Washington,
to lobby Congress.
You know, ordinary simple, poor black folk.
I mean, there's not much vote to lobby in Congress,
but their presence is a statement.
And the House Office buildings are connected to the halls of Congress
by long tunnels on the wrong tunnels that have a platform on the side of them.
And somebody else, I could take credit.
We didn't know what to do with the people.
We couldn't get them all.
There was a couple, maybe a couple hundred in it.
People really collected money to come to the lobby.
You know, they were really into it.
I mean, there was one group that was furious in funds.
I forget which stone it was.
And there was funds to get the bus to bring their people.
And then they sat again and they reflected and said,
well, you know, if the people got the right of bus to come up there,
they really can speak to the Congress as poor, fully as intelligent as they want.
And so they should really go on a plane.
So they were going to go, there's more funds to send.
Their representatives are on a plane,
so they could speak properly.
So all these people were there writing on to do with them.
And they were like, why don't we line them up on the platforms in the tunnel,
even from the whole office building to the store of the Congress?
And that's what they did.
And I was in there with them that morning.
And there was this line of black folks from Mississippi all in the Sunday dress,
which is already pretty straight beer.
And we told them not to say anything.
They could weave or they could nod,
but please don't say not to stand there or want these people to see you.
Because we don't want you to be abstract,
statistic-want you to be real people and know who they're voting against.
And I stood there and I saw these congressmen coming down there with their little teams,
their aids and stuff.
And when they turned the corner and look up and there's this line of silent black people,
line in the tunnel, you know, stop, I can just stop back.
And so we got to smile and kind of weave.
And the people were standing there looking at them.
And they got very self-conscious.
So I believe that might have affected the wood.
It had to have affected some of them, you know.
Because of the very powerful moment.
And then I ran up to the,
I ran up to the gallery.
And we resorted people to stand in and the tunnel.
We couldn't get seats in the gallery for them, you know.
We had to do some, we wanted them to feel it or participate in it some way.
And I ran up to the gallery.
And first of all,
you have to have a communist got to recognize Ryan and ask the Mississippi answer step aside.
Then the, his swears and the hoes.
And then they take a vote whether the Mississippi and should stay a said or not.
All right.
And that vote is very important because his advice vote.
McCommick's ears is good enough.
So you hear what you want to hear.
The eyes have it.
Okay.
And this over.
So you need to have a roll call vote.
But for a roll call vote, you need some like 60 voters, 60 congressmen got to claim a roll call vote, right?
So we didn't think we'd get a roll call vote.
We thought the victory was getting them to stand a said.
And.
Tank him from a comics is the host raised to this one.
And little congressman ran jump to his feet.
And when I look behind him, a wall of congressmen was standing up like 60 guys stood up.
I said, oh my god, almost fainted.
I mean, just people are so fast back to the rink rise and I've even saw John Conyers was rising up everybody.
I mean, 60 people stood up.
There is no way John McCommick could miscede them, right?
Says the congressman ran is is pro-design in congress.
And why does the congressman rise?
I rise to challenge the seating for the congressman from the second district, the third district and the fifth district of Mississippi.
And the Mississippiians had to stand aside.
That was the first shot they've got.
The first shot was when they saw how many of their colleagues rose up.
And this then McCommick went to do a vice vote and ran.
Chances I call for a roll call vote.
And who supports rands call and we have a guy stood up against that had to have a roll call vote.
And once they had a roll call vote, given the claim it in the country,
147 of the congress of the House of Representatives voted to unseat the Mississippiians to vacate the seats at least for the time being.
And 290, is that the right figure or 100 and I think it's 290 or something like that, 2904 voted against us.
Where this 75 votes had changed.
If the 75 would have come over to us, that's what I've been taught to 150 wouldn't it?
Because we would get them and they would lose them.
So we would have won, right?
We would have won handily.
75 votes is out of the tent.
And that was amazing enough.
And we can get that record.
We can go and look at the Congressional record for January 1965.
Hold that vote went.
Now remember we are starting from where Mitchell and them saying that we're not going to get a single congressman to raise the challenge.
And we're not going to get a single vote.
Let 104 to 7 votes.
Without the assistance of the NAACP, the UAW, the other resident liberal hierarchy.
So we did that on our own.
If they had been support, then so might have kept them out.
I mean I'm so exaggerated.
This is the result beyond anything we had expected.
I'm walking out to the gallery.
And I said, Joseph Rauh and Karen Smith, she'll just come in.
Now I don't know why they weren't in the gallery to watch you walking out of Congress.
Maybe this is a formality.
Not that important.
But no, they're rustling coming in.
They got pencil and paper in their hands.
I coin out to do it.
They said, Mike, what was the vote?
I said, 147 to 196.
And they raised it down.
And they added to it.
I dropped it to 100.
All right?
Joseph Rauh looks up.
You know the trick of it.
I'm curious about that.
I'm curious.
Karen Smith says, shit, this doesn't add up.
Let's go ask somebody intelligent.
And they're stalled off.
I was really happy to take that.
Look, I could see how agitated they were.
We've got redone this auto.
One of those, they're support, they're patronage or whatever it is.
And I'm forgetting the name of the ex-governor of Mississippi.
Coolman.
Somebody coolman.
J.C.
Coolman, right?
He looked like another product of central casting and really is
long white here in his supposed, but he's a gentlemanly segregationist.
And he was defending the Congress people.
Now, he had completely ignored, coincidently ignored,
and he was very concerned, can no.
I'm pretended I didn't exist, because I had no political power.
After that vote, he sought the vote and accepted from them a subpoena
to come and be, to testify, to come and be subpoenaed.
Come and be very quiet, deposed to give a deposition.
And the media in the state of Mississippi
talked about the day of infamy and the day of this grace.
Oh, 147 of their colleagues had turned their back on the state of Mississippi
and voted against the sovereign state of Mississippi and as a deadness grace
that will live forever.
But the government sent out instructions to every vote in registrar,
to every elected official, every local official, to accept all his subpoenas to testify.
In other words, that gave, even though they voted, to seat them.
That vote, to stand down, gave momentum to the challenge.
And then the lawyers, killed, and a few other lawyers' organizations,
came forward and volunteered.
So, hundreds of lawyers flocked to the state to start deposing these local officials.
And, you know, these white registrars, these white sheriffs,
these white local officials who treated black people like,
like, didn't mean anything.
They had no importance.
They suddenly had to come and testify.
And they started to send an invitation that they should come to the state host,
they should come to the court host, they should come to the contest.
And we said, no, no, don't do that.
Let them come to black churches.
Let them come into all community.
So these white folks had to come across the tracks into black churches,
into the black community, to be deposed.
And MFDP members packed those meetings.
And people, you know, local people would ask them questions.
And it's all at so and so and so and so.
And the lawyers from the South came in.
And it was a great psychological picture from the people in Mississippi.
So that's the story of voting, hit it.
When Congress reconvened after that vote,
then the whole question of the legislative agenda comes into play.
And we're trying to get the vote.
The civil rights act had been passed.
But for obvious reason, there was no voting provision in there,
because the whole lily white South was predicated on that.
They didn't think they could get it passed.
So that's what we wanted.
And we kept saying that.
And I kept saying that.
We kept saying that in the leadership conference, Dr. King kept saying
Rev. Walter Fauntroy, voting rights act, core kept saying it.
So finally, the administration sent Congressman Senator Proxmar,
I think it was from Wisconsin, a little sandy here in fellow.
And he came in to say that the administration has been discussing voting rights.
And they had the language and the general outland of a voting rights act,
which I wanted to share with us.
This I know understand to have been a trial balloon.
You send it up to see who does like.
Okay, I got a pullover envelope on which was scroll information.
That's how formal it was.
And the back of the sound of your right to us that the president and the Congress
were prepared to pass a vote on rights bill, in which in every county
our political entity, in which less than 10% of black people were registered to vote.
Less than 10%.
The president could send voting registrars to register all citizens.
And that was the best legislation that they could come up with at the time.
And this was the extent that the administration was willing to go.
And that was the extent of the legislation that the political climate in the country
would in the Congress would support.
And now, you know, when these people come to the leadership conference,
there's a whole set of protocols and rhetoric that they go through.
One of them, by obligation, is to call Clarence Mitchell Jr the 101st Senator.
That's 100th and 1st Senator, you know, they call it by tender that they call it by the,
that's the most willing greatest compliment the Senate can pay.
So, approximately I come to say I'm so glad to be here at leadership conference
with my old friend, my great old friend Clarence Mitchell Jr, the 101st Senator.
And now he's grinning going on and they end up.
And Dr. King was in tone at the.
Dr. King was in tone.
But he had, was the computer different meat and Rev. Walter Fauntroy brought him in.
He had left.
And I don't recall that King was in there when Prakz Mayor gave this language,
this project, full of voter rights act.
And Clarence Mitchell Jr walked back to King Old and came back and said,
Oh Dr. King says that that proposal is perfectly acceptable.
And that, that seems acceptable to me.
And I raised my hand and said, who a lot of minutes is this really acceptable?
And he said, all right, that ends all discussion.
Meat andness adjourned.
And then he turns to me and says, I said, but you know, I represent people here.
And there's something they want to say.
And as he walked up, it always said, over his shoulder, send a memorandum.
Big mistake.
So I went out and I wrote this memorandum.
And I said, look, Prakz Mayor of Wisconsin came and told us that the
voter rights act being contemplated said that we're ever more than 10% less than 10% of
black people were registered towards.
The president could send voter rights registrar.
I said, there's two things wrong with that.
If it has to be less than 10%, that means you have to have 90%, 91% discrimination.
Does that mean in the face of the federal government, 90% discrimination,
disfranchisement is all right?
I said, only in those states, those principalities, we are by great sacrifice of life,
of job, of personal safety.
We managed to get, oh, people managed to get more than 10% of them say 10% are more registered.
Then that means that they're not going to get any support from the federal government.
Then the fact is the legislation has presented as no teeth.
The president could send registrars.
That means he doesn't have to.
It's not automatic.
That means that what he given them is a stick to beat,
Southern Rukalsich and some of them, congressman, all they had would say, if you're mess with me,
I'm going to send voting registrars to your district.
That is not acceptable.
It's not acceptable to me.
To us is not acceptable to all constituents that we represent.
If this is, in fact, honest, and this is the best political solution that a climate of opinion in the Congress can come up with,
it is also the activist elements of the civil rights movement to go into the streets of this nation
and create a climate of opinion where we can get decent, vote-in-right legislation.
That's how it ended.
But when I call her on, of course, James Forman would say it for SNCC.
Of course, whoever the guy who exists in Farma would say it for CORE.
And Andrew Young called me up.
In fact, he called me up when I was up here at the University of Massachusetts,
explaining why I couldn't come.
He called me up to say that Martin Luther King would say it.
So that meant SNCC CORE Martin Luther King.
And Lawrence Gear could send for the MFDP.
The one mistake I made was I sent it out on MFDP letterhead.
And I hadn't thought about it.
God, that's a letter that I used.
But all those signatures were there.
And it was a memorandum address to the leadership conference,
because the clients which is, they send a memorandum.
The only feedback I got from the signatories was,
Jim, whatever his name was, from CORE.
The executive.
CISIC.
No, not McKissick.
From McCain.
No.
Forget his name.
He called up as a...
CORE Farma?
Not Farma.
This is the guy who really handled matters.
A white boy.
There was a McCain, too, McCain.
No.
Well, he called up and said, you betrayed us.
I said, wait.
He said, but I thought this memorandum would grow.
It's on a blank letter, a no letterhead at all,
and from all people equally.
It was sent out on the MFDP letterhead as a...
I said, oh my God.
I really didn't think about it.
I'm terribly...
I see what you're saying now.
I hadn't thought about it.
It's a letterhead we always used.
But nobody else had any objection.
Except that the leadership conference.
We were meeting every week, because the letterhead
to a gender is coming into place.
It didn't meet.
And there was a next week where it didn't meet again.
There's two weeks of leadership conference didn't meet.
Then somebody told me that Clarence Mitchell Jr had had a heart attack.
A male heart attack.
Said that I'd call him a traitor and that I would say no.
And he would call him nothing.
That he was still no black people.
And that he was in Puerto Rico recuperating.
But they didn't meet.
So obviously that memorandum, I would dock the King's signature
particularly on it.
I'm going to tell all these church groups where he members here.
And because the logical is just the memorandum,
I want you to get for me.
The logical is irreproachable.
I mean we're less than 10%.
91% this French has been susceptible.
So a complicate or so shown as this being told is of the administration.
So it's never meet.
But making worse.
Now remember what the last paragraph said.
What the last paragraph said.
The president can.
No, no.
No, no, no.
My memorandum.
No, you're memorandum.
Oh, did you get people in the streets and memorandums?
Let us create it.
If this is in fact the truth, this is the political climate
in Washington, Cantala, let us create a political climate in the country
that will give us real voting rights.
And you can find out the data that memorandum.
Because in the two or three weeks that they didn't meet,
Selma happened.
And it looked.
And it's sheer coincidence.
It's just kind of like you come into the country and the city.
Sheer cool incidents.
I mean we couldn't have planned it.
We couldn't have planned Jim Clark and his fucking party beating up people
on the Elmepetus bridge.
You know what?
The two things happened one after the other.
And during the time when the leadership conference didn't meet,
there obviously in great disarray.
And the leadership of Joseph Rauh and Clarence Mitchell Jr were completely scattered
because Walter Walter Reuther sent out a telegram to all members of the leadership conference.
I remember Robert Spike, I said, Jesus Christ.
Did you ever think so vulgar?
In the first paragraph it mentions a million dollars.
In the first paragraph Walter Walter Reuther said that EW,
we were going to set up a fund of a million dollars to endow the survivors
of masters of the civil rights movement.
And in the second paragraph he said he was calling the meeting.
And it's the audience members of the leadership conference to meet and to discuss
policies and movement forward.
He obviously was freaking to move into a vacuum to take over because obviously
Joseph Rauh and Mitchell were discredited to the NAACP leadership.
That's when that meeting in the member of the Courtland Cox came
and Clarence Mitchell Jr was saying, well, they're really president of the leadership conference
as well.
Roy Wilkins, I have to serve in his place as a Washington representative.
And courtland, look at what I'm saying.
So, what are real kids?
Is the chairman of the leadership conference?
Where is that engraved and storm?
I'm sorry, but it's not written anywhere.
So it's folklore.
Courker.
I mean Clarence Mitchell Jr, Algo is fit to.
And the other hardest part?
And so look at Richard and his leadership.
Anyway, Walter Walter Reuther calls this meeting and gets who he brings to speak for him.
But of course, got bad always.
And we respected and looked at you bad, well, and respected.
So, back him and say, here's what we're going to do.
We're going to end all this million dollar thing to take care of the martyrs.
And there's five of these other martyrs of the civil rights movement.
And we're going to say that our organization to conduct the business of civil rights over.
And I just read that area as a question.
I said, OK.
We're this endowment for the martyrs.
We're the widow of Malcolm X and his daughters.
We recipients.
We have a beneficiary.
A long sentence.
By the jaw dropped.
The Irish had been thought of it.
Walter Walter Reuther said next to him looked very strange.
And the second question is, who would be present when this statement got a whole national media,
where Gathe d'Ode said, right?
What kind of statement is going to be to the assembly press and what would we tell them?
And I couldn't answer that question.
So he meets and woke up in confusion.
Went back to the office and the phone rings and it's Walter Walter Reuther.
And he wanted to know whether I would have dinner with him.
I said, well, you know, Mr. Ruther, on two conditions.
Number one, it has to be in the key's restaurant, a black restaurant, long silence.
And then the other hand, the rest of my staff would have to come.
My office died.
There's four of us.
Is that OK?
Is that all right?
I went out and I found out if Jan was much more political, he said, OK, then he said, you idiot.
He was fixing to offer you a job.
Why do you think you wanted to have dinner with you?
I said, well, I didn't want the job of the red array.
So the whole staff went out and had dinner.
Very stiff, pointless, dude, I was very much fun.
We'd want to lose and the red here, the lady, at the key's restaurant.
And the Voting Rights Act of 1965 after Selma was rewritten to have a very real positive effect on the political history of the country and the South.
And I considered that at Memorandum, which I love to see, had a great deal to contribute to that, because they were ready to say that that was acceptable, you know.
More than 10% of the French-Aisement and stuff like that.
So I consider it a slight contribution to history.
All right.
Now, remember I told you, home with a book, the comic book, it was way, way too long, and how the editor was a very good editor, a stigma of everything which didn't seem to drive the central narrative.
One of the parts in there was a little section dedicated to Jesse Harris.
And it told a story of a young Mississippi black man, when the Freedom Rides had finally come free from Alabama, his head of the tours, Mississippi.
He learned that they were coming and he went to the bus station to meet them.
There had been planned another reception of black people there.
And that was when the crackers who were understated went into Parchman Farm, got somebody, they were described artists, black criminals, the guys who were there from manslaughter or murder and said to them,
we know you always want to kick some way to us where you got a chance, no.
We're going to take it to the bus station when these Freedom Rides come and watch you film up completely.
And you'll get liquor, you'll get women, and you'll get easier time when you come back.
At about 10 or 12 black criminals that they had that way.
And they thought about it for a minute, shot the left feet and said, captain, I don't believe I will.
And none of them would agree to come to the bus station to meet up the Freedom Rides.
Which is when I think the single most heroic because when your black prison department indoors days your life has no guarantees, you know.
None of them would do it.
But there was one black, Mississippi, in whom I had the Freedom Rides.
I know I'm 17 year old kid named Jesse Harris.
And he walked into the white, changing room, white, waiting room with the Freedom Rides, with the black Freedom Rides as the white ones walked into the black, with room.
And he got arrested.
But he wasn't a freedom raider. His name wasn't any less nobody knew him.
He was a local kid.
So they sent him to the contrary jail and they sent the Freedom Rides someplace else.
The Freedom Rides had some modest protection because after all the violence and Alabama and stuff, the deal Robert Kennedy caught was that there wouldn't be brutalized and they were treated in a certain way.
And the justice department was paying attention.
But nobody was paying attention to Jesse Harris, the local kid who had sent off by himself to the contrary found.
And one day one of the walking buses told him to do some.
And Jesse said, yes.
And the walking bus said, yes what?
You mean yes or don't you?
And Jesse said, only says sir to my daddy or to people I respect.
I said a walking bus said, okay boy, I don't know where they are.
And he sent for wrong message which was a big strap.
And he tore up for Jesse's ass.
Oh, beat him up. Sorry, I gave him a hour of whipping.
And Jesse stood up after that. His legs were trembling. He was weak from shock.
And the cracker said to him, I guess you know how to say son, don't you war.
And Jesse just looked at him and turned around and lay back down on the log.
I let this end sense where he can beat me so more.
And the guy didn't have the conscience to continue beating Jesse.
Jesse, of course, John Student Nonviolent Coordinating Committee. He became project director in McComb, Mississippi.
He ran the security for Martin Luther King when he came to Mississippi.
He was a legitimate hero to speak when Student Nonviolent Coordinating Committee.
And after the movement employed it, he became a Muslim minister.
Then that broke up.
And he got involved with drugs.
I think he became an addict to serve some time in jail.
And then he disappeared.
Charlie Cobb went down looking for him.
And couldn't find him anywhere. He had disappeared.
And Charlie reminded me that Jesse had told him, you know, that as a youth,
he used to carry the contract club in Jackson.
And he used to hustle those crackers for money.
And I said, is that possible?
Charlie said, that's what they asked him.
I said, Jesse, you really used to hustle those crackers for money?
And Jesse said, yes, Charlie.
It could be done, which you had to play a very careful game.
So I included that in the book as a tribute to the disappeared Jesse,
when we all thought was dead.
And that's one of the things I wanted to quote McCartney,
didn't drive the narrative.
And I said, no, no.
It's an epitaph for Jesse.
He might have disappeared, but he has to leave some record in the world.
And so she kept it.
And the book came out.
And I went to Jackson for a launch in Abu Khridin, a reading.
I went out there, the room was buzzing.
I said, guess who's back?
Guess who's back?
Guess who came back?
Jesse, Jesse Harry came back.
I said, oh my God.
And then when I went to talk to Jesse right quick, he said, you know,
why do you have been?
He said, he'd even been to Jamaica working in a construction crew.
And but I already went to a study of worksite and to the bars.
And he said, you know, I sit in the bars and people
be talking about the civil rights movement.
I never opened my mouth.
God, who's going to believe I will neglect me?
I said, Jesse, read this.
And I showed him the passage in the book that told his story.
And I just watched him as he read it very slowly, very carefully.
And I just smiled across his face when he was finished.
I said, Jesse, what do you think?
He said, damn it, Mike.
I sure was by one eye.
I said, yes, you were, Jesse.
And the next time you go to a bar, I want to talk about knowing Martin Luther King
and being involved in the movement.
You take this book with you.
And if anybody challenges your veracity, you just show them that passage.
How did you end up here at the University of Massachusetts?
Sheer accident and by the good offices of the FBI.
One day, I am a foreign student, always have been.
And I was here on a foreign student's visa.
When I was sitting in my office at a Mississippi Freedom Democratic Party
in Washington, DC, and in walks these two suits,
they're kind of discomforted to be there.
And they turned out to be men from the FBI.
And they said to me, Mr. Thelwell, you are the director of this office, I said, yes sir.
They said, you are, are you not a foreign student?
I said, yes sir, I am.
They said, you made a pledge when you came here not to involve yourself.
And the internal affairs of the country did you not?
I said, yes sir.
They said, how would you describe what you do and know?
I said, well, I'm trying to unseat three unfairly elected people who,
this franchise, this black people and this, if you're trying to beat the currency of a American democracy.
They said, be that as it may Mr. Thelwell.
If you're not in school by September, and this is about June or July,
we shall personally come in and squat you to the plane and deport you from the country.
I think they were in a bad mood when they left.
But still a much better conduct enough of their fears and they would do no.
Now I know they'd kick my ass out immediately, you know?
So in some ways the country has not really improved.
And they also were, I think a little bit pissed because Len Holt, a SNCC lawyer,
the lawyer came busting in, I think to defend me and said, who are these gentlemen, Mike?
I said, Len, they're from the FBI.
He said, oh, the FBI.
And how is our favorite girlfriend this morning?
I said, your favorite girlfriend?
He said, yes, it's J. Edgar Hoover.
So that didn't put a nice spin on her fears.
So they left.
So I had a meet and then I said, you know, they said they're going to put me on a sandbag in school.
I said, oh my God, I got a letter from Sidney Kaplan offering me a fellowship,
but they threw it away.
And Joanne Gavin, the office manager, said, yeah, I put a little to the waist basket.
So there was a letter from Kaplan.
And that in the long, and the short of it is how I ended up here.
But the longer story is also quite interesting because all my time in the movement had never had a conversation with Martin Luther King.
But I think it was about, let's say, a memorandum on the Voting Rights Act.
I had to run up here to explain to them in the middle of the summer that I couldn't be here when school started in September.
Because I had to see the challenge out.
And I didn't know if the Congress would vote on the challenge by early September so I could be here at school open.
So I said, I would have to miss a week, maybe two with that be happy to start.
The chairman of the department and the head of freshman English class, supposed to be teaching.
He said, well, you know Mr. Thelwell, you've never been in graduate school before.
It's a little more rigorous.
I'm sure there was a thing that I'm coming from at Black School.
I don't know nothing.
I said, yes, so at that time, sure I'd be able to pick up the work.
Well, we don't really know.
And they were about to say that either I'd be here on time or not come at all.
We don't know if you can have two weeks.
When the secretary runs in and says, is this Mr. Thelwell?
I said, yes, you have a phone call.
And the chairman of the department and the head of freshman English looked really, very disapproving.
Imagine this student having a phone call, why didn't conference with us.
I said, no, my back, I can't take the phone call.
I'm really, very busy here.
She says, no, I think you really want to take this phone call.
So there, I was going people more.
And I said, why is that, man?
She said, because it's from Dr. Martin Luther King.
And who, atmosphere change?
And I said, yes, I could go have the phone call.
And if I had been smart enough, I'd have got my office to call and pretend that.
But it really wasn't even from Dr. King.
It was from Andrew Young, calling for Dr. King to clarify something about that memorandum
where earlier discussed at which point the chairman of the department,
was a Southern gentleman by the way, a white Southern gentleman.
And the director of freshman English said, well, yes, I could have a couple of weeks if it weren't necessary.
But then the director of freshman English told me what I shouldn't talk about in class when I was teaching freshman English.
The only subjects which you should avoid is politics, religion, and sex.
Those are not acceptable.
And I said, well, perhaps you'd be good enough to tell me what is acceptable.
So I went back to DC.
And they had sent me my class list.
I was supposed to teach because the fellowship was gone to the government's citizenship.
And I had two class list that were, you know, well, I answered a lot of mere genes and Susan and stuff like this.
Well, they sent me back a class list.
And we have decided that in the view of your inexperience issue on the Teach One course.
And when I looked at the list, it was the freshman football team.
Nothing but men.
But I think that was clearly a coincidence.
The leadership conference met again for the first time after Long Hiatus.
And I walked into the room and there is Lawrence Mitchell, Pufferman Hoffen.
And he's saying, yes, I was called a traitor in a cello.
And Evans and Novak and those other columnist had one story about who the students were trying to wreck the civil rights movement.
And they had forged duck to king signature on a memorandum, which was calculated to destroy the harmonious civil rights movement.
Well, I've done an issue and the young had called me, but you must, you know.
And he said, yes, and we're going to talk about the misuse of Dr. King's name and the fortune of his name.
And bad Russen is here with a statement from Dr. King.
And I said, oh, if Dr. King the Nobel Prize winner says I've marked that, well, let's make student for his name on the memorandum, who the fuck is going to believe me?
And the memorandum, by the way, didn't have this radical and disruptive language.
It was very logical, which is why I wanted you to get it from it, please.
And Bayard Rustin. And I'm sitting here with my heart in my mouth saying, my professional reputation is done by character with the traduce.
I hope Martin Luther King knows the a forges memor because I didn't.
And Bayard Rustin on a rota statement, which said absolute and nothing.
And then he stopped. Dr. King says he believes the time and solips abilities necessary and harsh language shouldn't be used and blah, blah, blah.
And then he stuck and asked which is it. Is that all? Is that all?
But I said, yes, that is all. And Michelle looked very disappointed to try to never talk about fortune, King's name.
So I was very grateful to Dr. King, but then hopefully you lay, you know, being Dr. King.
But I noticed that bad scratched out a last paragraph.
So after it was around two minutes, I think about can I have that document, please, I say sure you can have it.
But the last three lines of that statement had been scratched out so so thoroughly that there were holes in the paper.
You couldn't read what it said, but it never said that there for a job, King's name, which I didn't do.
And that was very principle of Dr. King and Bayard Rustin that they were on the pressure because all these economists were saying what a disruptive document.
Document it was that Dr. King couldn't possibly have said such a disruptive and radical document and that this name had to be forged, but he didn't say it.
This has been a presentation of LoC + Smithsonian NMAAHC.